what up guys welcome to the just per
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame every clap every clap yeah
okay before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in we have a extra
special panel today um this is like the
most unique panel I think I've ever had
um why don't we go around everyone give
me your background name age relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself
starting there and then go around all
right my name is sunny Fazzio I'm
currently single got a couple little
side things no I'm just joking my
mother's here so no I'm single but um
yeah I'm specialized in short form
marketing that's what I do fulltime I
run my Sunny Faz YouTube channel I've
made a lot of videos with my mom and
I've kind of been making different type
of content lately I'm from Boston
Massachusetts anything else did I miss
anything
good top Z I am John zurka the biggest
sexist racist misogynist online there's
never been a higher level of free speech
than me I believe Jesus is King I will
see a Catholic theocracy before I'm done
on Earth everyone who's not a Catholic
will be arrested under my order unless
this is this is comedy and if I get in
trouble for this check it out I
believe you cannot have the Bible back
in the education system without Free
Speech cuz the Bible says LGBT gay as
[__] that's why I sound like this but my
nature is actually politically correct I
just do this for the entertainment
aspect to get the clickbait but deep
down I'm a
softy okay uh my name is
[__] [__] ass what go ahead you GNA
say this show list I believe we all have
souls that's what I believe and I
believe everyone on this table all all
your opinions are wrong because you're
not morally grounded in the Bible the
Bible
says a man at can't spell lie without
Bible a man at 18 we're going to trust a
Jew a man at 18 a man at 18 has
authority over all women on earth that's
him he's 18 you have authority over all
women on earth that's what the how old
says I'm 20
okay anyways uh my name is Gary the
numbers guy I did what uh Michael Jordan
said he was going to do I dominate my
field numerology and astrology I got a
billion views this year on IG Tik Tok
and that's why uh Pearl allows me to
Grace her with my
presence hi I'm Tony Scardino I'm my
nurse my perus at nurse what the hell
nurse I'm 23 years old born and raised
Las Vegas and I have my own podcast
where I talk about Society distracting
us from our higher self higher
purpose and it's a little gay Shout Out
free will oh relationship status and I'm
single oh we have to do that okay hi I'm
you can you can grab the mic hi I'm
Elena I'm Sunny faz's mom and I am on
content with sunny and thanks uh born
and raised in Brooklyn New York and
lived in Boston for a long time and now
I do content yeah I was was the Yankee
fan in Boston for a lot of years and um
that's got to be dangerous I do cultural
commentary
and I am actually working on a
documentary to fight the sexualization
of children in American schools and how
creepy it all is oh
single and as a pedophile I object I'm
kidding it's a joke God you imagine if I
start Zera why do you want a
theocracy because then every man would
be guaranteed a virgin wife and we'd
reduce crime by 99% right yeah okay a
virgin wife in this country that's the
reason yes marriage marriage is the End
Game of Life it's not career marriage is
everything to Salvation is the end game
of Catholicism you beat me yeah she's
cooking women one men zero yeah because
by that Lo by that logic wouldn't nuns
not get Sal like wouldn't nuns not well
I'm just saying to reduce crime rate you
want married people right I agree with
that yeah I agree with that so how would
that work just like medieval times
right you lock up the woman you keep her
with her dad and then he chooses out of
20 Partners which one she should marry
or he he gives her a selection and she
can choose in in a just Society uh when
a daughter is born to a man uh a Chassy
belt would go on that key to the Chassy
belt would be on the man's neck and then
when they find a man who's suitable
enough to protect the daughter then the
man who obviously have a wedding you
take the key and you know this would be
a big ceremony the father takes the key
to the chassis Bel and gives it to the
husband and I think um that's how
Society should be but it's not going to
happen what do what do you guys think
what do you guys think of that I mean
yeah it makes sense because back then
women were the prize and Men these are
not omnidirectional so no one can hear
you you have to speak into it yeah you
guys are pass you're going to be muted
for most of that say it again got it
okay so I do agree with that because
women back in the day they were the
prize and men would Chase and fight for
them and then yeah I don't think women
were ever the prize Well I think in
their point right there if the woman a
DI piece is always a prize if woman
matter I I think chivalry is gynocentric
I think the order of the world goes God
men women and children the woman cannot
be the prize because she's always below
the what what if people don't believe in
God well I mean I have I have I have a
Catholic worldview but even if you don't
believe in God I would say when you look
at Society like the woman should always
be with a man that she thinks is the
prize I just don't think relationships
work otherwise I think that defeats the
run and chase Vibe right don't men
usually Chase explain that more so
usually in a dynamic a man is chasing a
woman a woman is usually Ray so you
saying that the woman is not the prize
completely defeats the fact that men are
chasing well I I would argue that that's
like a more romantic love which
developed in the last thousand years
before that it wasn't really about love
yeah before that someone hit you on the
head drag you by the hair and take you
back to their cave yeah right cira
clubbing go clubbing yeah right I mean I
I really think somewhere in between the
clubbing and where we are today you know
smaller Club a little past the chastity
belt is where I'd like to see you know
just the just the physical confinement
is I like the uh I like it as a
symbolism helping a woman to to be pure
but by protecting her not with iron with
morals and kind of you know kidding
about the chassis belt [__] but I'm not
really because let me ask you this how
many lives would that chassity belt
control save more than gun control well
if you think about abortion alone how
many lives would that save about a
million a year again so CH about control
would work yes I would really like to
get to a place where people have some
moral decency and we don't need to lock
them up I would like to get on on the
place where I can walk the streets at
2:00 in the morning but that's not
really going to happen yeah I grew up in
that world let's can we dial it back to
the 1950s first I'm down the 19 if we
could go back to Twilight Zone 1950s
I'll start there I don't need to be
chopping heads right now I will be happy
with the 1950s we just want to dial it
back to there H the first sexual
Revolution started in the 20s but 50s is
definitely better than today so yeah
they were staying together married
couples were staying
together I mean a lot of them got
divorced when um no fault divorce was
implemented in the 70s like it like the
divorce rate the birth the childless
rate started falling 150 years ago um
the div for white for white people not
for everybody but it was still uncommon
in the 70s I can tell you now like
looking at Sun like Sunny's class who
who he came up with the majority of the
parents were divorced where when I was a
kid I think there was one or two
divorced kids that I knew you know with
kids with divorced divorced parents it
was very uncommon women women knew their
place back then well people stuck
together and and I think part of that
was cuz a lot of women weren't working
so they they they had to stay even if
they weren't happy you know and you know
they kind of hope that their husband die
or women leaving the workforce fixes all
the problems in America all of them it
does repeal
19 yeah I'd argue women voting I kept I
kep is everyone agreeing oh my God I
kept telling people I kept telling
people the coid 19 did nothing even
close to the 19th Amendment the 19th
amendment was way worse than Co 19 yeah
well because women will even the co the
co
stuff I mean I would argue I would argue
the co stuff is because of women because
women when there's fear women will
always pick um security Safety and
Security over Freedom that's why they're
communist in nature yeah and the
anti-suffragist knew this they literally
warned us it's really eerie when you
read their writings because they're like
no like it's like all these wives and
mothers that got together and we're like
we cannot give women the right to vote
because if you do you're going to see
increased government spending you're
going to see the breakdown of the family
and it's really eerie because everything
they predicted came true you know what
what one of the biggest facts that most
people never even think about in the 18
in the
1860s um that's when they gave the black
man the right to vote in America uh
people that the racist white people back
then considered three-fifths of person
were given the right to vote before
their own women so again the black black
man had the right to vote 60 years
before the white woman that means the
racist white men of the 1800s thought
more about what they considered slaves
than their own women I think that says
it all that says a lot but here's the
thing though there was a time when let's
let's just say you're right for the sake
of the conversation that women shouldn't
vote but a lot of that reason is because
they're emotional and they're not making
logical decisions and maybe they're not
as smart as men right that's true right
right just
I'm I'm making it but look at what's
happened to look at what what's happened
to me young men in America today they
have demasculinized them and feminize
them to the point that they are Little
Women running around and there's you
know some some fathers and mothers are
still raising masculine men but this
vast majority of feminine men I'm more
scared of their vote to be honest who
created them who created them the single
mothers and the feminists created them
they they don't have any fathers in
their lives and then these people turn
into beta mail so it all goes back Tois
the same then nobody votes
nobody I would AR I would argue there's
three ways that you should be able to
vote number one military fine we'll give
like the 5% of women that are in the
military whatever the right to vote okay
second net taxpayers women earn a lot of
debt um I don't think you should get the
right to vote if you've taken child
support or alimony and the third thing I
would say um is infrastructure job so if
you're doing a job that runs the
infrastructure firefighter policeman and
if you just do those three things most
women can't vote
anyways well um a majority of 45% of men
if you expand the definition of
infrastructure to involve things like
truckers um it's like 45% of men that
are involved in an infrastructure job
but why does only infrastructure allow
you to vote so like you know how the
saying Rome isn't built in a day Society
is clearly man and woman so men doing
infrastructure there jobs to build
Society I I don't find women's jobs to
be as useful or needed in society I'll
give you an example if we look at the
billionaires in society we have Oprah
and we have Elon Musk who provides more
value who's more needed Jeff Bezos or
Kim Kardashian and and even let's like
let's look at educ gives away buses
education right even let's look at
education education was primarily male
dominated in the 1850s so what's
happened the last 150 years since women
have taken over education it's terrible
they they got a whole bunch because the
problem is women will always default to
egalitarianism we always want everyone
to be included we always want to make
like men are competitors they will
naturally compete and organize
themselves in hierarchy women do not do
this so when they take both no not in
the workforce I you think a society not
on the mic you think Society ran by just
men what what would you think that yeah
I think think think I think it would
look the same way it's always looked for
the past thousand years when men have
always ran Society it it would they're
running them now it's running men run
Society Jo bid Joe Biden is president of
the United States because single mothers
put him in there so obviously the women
put this feminist piece of garbage down
you think our vote put Joe Biden yes yes
no I know it is because the last hundred
years it would have been conservative
conservatives would have won the last
hundred years because all of the
politicians are catering to the female
vote female are the number one swing
voters all of the propaganda is Catered
towards women because they know women
are easily swayed by their emotions so
what they'll typically do is they'll
show a a sad story and here's the policy
that takes away your freedom she's
cooking right now I think in the United
States men and women are almost equal
they're 50% that's the problem no
they're not wouldn't there be similar
voting if there's 50 like no
so go to divorce court and try to get
custody of your kids unless the mother
is an absolute piece of [__] like living
on the street hooker heroin addict she's
getting the kids she's get her important
role in society what that's her role in
society is to take care of her child
yeah but 80% of criminals come from
single mom not single dad households
that's why all the evil on Earth comes
from women so isn't it the absent father
where's the father yeah but yeah with
that statistic aren't like most single
parents moms yeah they are no where are
the women because the women are the ones
that
leave the father loses in court yeah so
what they do is they do a catch 22
traditional men are punished in this
country because what they'll do is
they'll say go protect and provide your
f for your family so the men go do it
then they take them to family court and
say gotcha you didn't spend enough time
with your kid well he was doing the
right thing he was working and if we
really wanted to do what was right for
the children they would give the kid to
the fathers because single father homes
by and large turn out significantly
better almost the same as two parent
homes women raise terrible kids as
single mothers there's exceptions
there's awesome single mothers out there
but the rule the exceptions do not make
the rule so you think women leave men
more over
men so you think most they're college
educated most of the no let's take more
like lowincome where men are going to
prison or they're you know what per of
men so so they so they survey so they
surveyed 5,000 men 2023 and they said
what percent of you have had multiple
sexual partners in the past year only
10% of men have had multiple sexual
partners in the past year I only 10% of
men can even cheat only 33% of men have
ever reported to having mult multiple
sexual partners 1% YouTube famous only
only only 33% of men have had answered
to having multiple sexual partners in
their lifetime so only one out of three
men can even cheat and the majority of
cheating is a one-time thing so the idea
just because we're all dating the same
men it does not mean the majority of men
are cheating yeah you're telling me a
majority of men only had one sexual
partner well so 10% of men said that
they had more than one sexual partner
this year 33% of men said in their
lifetime so you're married right so so
right now it would just be your wife but
at one point at one point corre corre
corre unless the wife is here okay okay
look look I'm not I'm just using you as
an example but but but I I'd imagine
that you could put that at one point in
your life that wasn't always the case so
no I married a virgin what I married a
virgin I did what everyone said they're
going to do no no no I wasn't I was okay
I'm saying if you had multiple sexual
partners at a different point in your
life only 33% of men have said at some
point me being alive I've had more than
one sexual partner in a year wow and
that was um it's either 2022 or 2023 I I
kind of look down on that that's all men
are pulling I kind of that's I that
that's kind of shameful because they've
cut off their coonies these young men
have no guts anymore to begin with
they've have been raised by women even
if they are in a two parent home women
who are trying to Tamp down on their
masculinity and tell them to lean into
their feelings and they get the the the
feeling they lean into is fear and then
you have the whole me too [__] where
that you know now you know like I tell
him like Hey just just a girl's drunk
just don't just leave it alone how
worried are you you have your son here
how worried are you that your son can
get me too because he is somewhat famous
yes I worry about that does that keep
you up at night no but we talk about it
I mean watch these ho Sunny I'm pretty
good about being careful with that stuff
like if they're I don't know there's
been plenty of times where I'm out with
a girl and they're too drunk and they
might want to do something and I'll shut
it down you know it's just it's never
worth it I've always tried to teach him
yeah lay off the drunk girls because you
don't know what she's going to say the
next day and you know don't talk out of
school after if you do a fool around
with a girl keep your mouth shut be a
gentleman about it you know don't go
bragging but not everybody's teaching
their young men that but why do it's
it's it pisses me off that I have to
teach him to be afraid of women because
the way these young women are being are
being taught they're trying to
masculinize them at the same time
everybody's confused and everyone's
acting like an [__] and it's really
Terri got to start signing
ndas pulling aen Ross well even and the
school system I've been I've been making
people sign non-disclosure since
2015 except me you do regret
this I've been leaking him so hard I'm
going to make sure this guy with this
head sidy three times one podcast we're
on and the the the stuff he gets people
assign for I just start babbling all
secet I don't have an NDA well you don't
you don't leave I just started babbling
all his secrets I'm like look what Gary
taught me and he calls me he's like what
the [__] are you doing and I'm like I'm
teaching them numerology and how to go
to the next level and it turns out it's
$222,000 for one sign up of that
lifetime course you have to pay 22,000
for that course and I'm leaking it for
free on a podcast that's why I rather
kill him than actually I'm the only
person he's at thousands of students he
he only believed in the Christian he
came with me he got me a he did all this
for me and then I leaked him I snaked
him by accident he he knows 5% of what I
teach no but bro
imagine what I from thousands of his
students zurka is the one that he said
ah you can sign that later you should
have had me sign it I didn't know I was
leaking you'll be signing you right
after we leave yeah I [__] up I [__]
up
G yeah that's I don't know I don't know
if that was Gary here's know I [__] up
because you actually taught me what to
stay away from I don't want to go into
this stuff too much but he said there's
one date a year you should avoid we met
her and I started arguing I'm like no I
want to see this girl he's like you
can't see her you can't bring her here
I'm like what the [__] do you know
within two days allegation my first in
10 years of working with women my first
allegation against me but then thank God
it was all recorded So I exposed their
ass but it was May 25th a women born on
May 25th
they have evil energy he was right about
that guys I want you to listen to me
I've been doing numerology and astrology
for 20 years if there's a [__] born on
May 25th run run like hell I learned the
hard way I said [__] do you know Gary
and I ran out the if there's a date
that's possessed it's May 25th man yeah
Gary looked me in the eyes and said if
you want to have sex with her not in our
house and so I ran away from content
house yeah he doesn't even live there
but he said to avoid that one number
within 24 hours and yo I never told him
for the first few days cuz I didn't want
that I Told You So parade so I just said
Gary she you're right she's a little
weird but it was allegation level weird
so that's why he tries to get me around
horse May May 25th is the one day I do
not allow in my group I will not let
anyone in on that date because I'm
telling you guys are watching this right
now they're thinking oh my God there's
probably going to be millions of people
watching this I'm telling you at least
10 to 15,000 guys are going to be elting
they like oh my God because May 25th
these [__] are [__] crazy as hell
so I said my piece go ahead bro well and
the other thing I was going to say about
like the the [__] men basically they're
all raised like they go from the single
mother home and then they go to the
school system that's all female so it's
like where do they even get male
guidance from that's what I'm trying to
say is where are the men you are not a
real man unless you push the woman don't
hit them but they're they're being
clipped being so I'll give you I'll give
you an example I'll give you an example
so I know a guy who's a really good um
music producer like he's really into
like music and he okay I I I don't know
I don't know
sing okay I don't we don't need his
number we know okay okay okay okay
anyways anyways but he he told me he
wanted to teach music in schools and one
day and it was at a really rich like
neighborhood School whatever and one day
this 15 year-old girl starts hitting on
him and he quit he said I quit that very
same day because I am not dealing with
like and that's something guys think
about it just takes one Chi what a
coward what I'm going for the meme bro I
don't care I'm joking um and it's also
not really a job women respect anymore
you know like girls aren't really lined
up to date teachers so what reward do
they get for doing that only pedophiles
look for those jobs now yeah if you're a
male teacher you're a pedophile like why
are you around kids that's just weird
well they used to be all male in the
1850s I don't think it was all pedophile
professors can be male but like with my
kids what they going to like no in the
1850s it was primarily male kindergarten
teacher as a male is weird as hell but
the problem now now it is now it is I
don't think it was no it because again
they they used to trust in male
Authority now they do not so that's like
changing diapers as a man lack of trust
for having that Authority
when you have a child what you going to
have your woman so what you got you
bring you bring home millions of dollars
and you have to change the diaper that's
crazy no no no hold on hold on I don't I
don't do it all the time if if if if
anything was 98% too but not even you
got to do it yourself Gary if I bring
millions of dollars for my wife I just
should have change one diaper if you you
if you love you will I don't even love
the baby if [__] if the baby thinks of
[__] I don't love you anymore well I'm
not saying well one I'm not saying that
they should be changing diapers but I
would say education is it used to be a
more structured hierarch like it used to
have a hierarchy and it used to be more
structured but now it's just like wild
here's the hierarchy um men don't listen
to women like if I'm on a road trip for
about two weeks and I come back from
Vegas or something like that the kids
are running wild yeah okay I basically
have to go in there and I can't be their
friend I got to yell at them ah do this
do this and then they still Ste down
within 24 hours because you need a man
no woman can teach a boy how to become a
man period I can tell you I'm one of
four girls 19 years ago my father died
and ever since he died there's been
Mayhem in the family that never existed
while he was alive and he was a nice
even keed calm guy he wasn't a tyrant
but for some reason he knew how to keep
everything it pulled together and it's
one anecdotal story but it really was a
loss in a lot would you would you be
would you be a liberal if it wasn't for
your father oh I would be I'd be in like
a hippie and a bus somewhere go strong
male figure well you were a liberal last
year to me now you're black pill a
liberal last year you weren't as
hardcore no no I I was not I was never
liberal really no no never liberal so
how long have you hated women
so but okay so I'll but I'll answer I'll
get to that next but I want to answer
your question first cuz you asked why is
there this distrust in men it's because
women respond really quickly to
propaganda and there's been a propaganda
wave since like the 60s saying the men
are abusive you can't trust the men this
has been going on for over 50 years and
women actually have no idea that women
are actually more violent than men yet
men are always the ones accused of abuse
Amber herd shout out to amberd so and
because what is what is true violence um
who kills the innocent women kill even
babies after they're born and the
elderly more than men it's not even
close then we look at abusive
relationships when it's when it's
one-sided meeting one part is hitting
the other and they're not just beat you
know you know some couples they just
beat each other up like Chan blue face
what you're talking about but when it's
one-sided it's 70% of the time it's the
women and and if you want to include
under reported like I would argue it's
under reported because men aren't really
going to report it like women are I
would argue it's higher than that women
are very very yeah and I I would even
argue that there's more I would argue
there's more stories of women beating
their kids than there are women are very
very violent but the media has convinced
us otherwise well it doesn't hurt like
once you're past the age of 12 yeah I
know I remember the first I remember I
remember the first time my mom like hit
me because she H me with this wooden
spoon I remember the first time she did
it and she didn't um like it didn't hurt
with the wooden spoon yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I was like I was like oh this
doesn't even hurt yeah do it again mom
wait are you part Italian or something I
thought that was just in our jeans no
I'm Irish you guys are Irish too yeah
we're 1 Irish right I'm aish you never
used The Wooden Spoon you would just
throw like slippers I think a couple
months ago you threw a bottle at me no
what do we there there's no microphone
in between you guys you guys keep moving
it when you rewatch this you guys will
be totally deafen I'm serious I've come
after you like a fewer times than I can
count on one hand like but sometimes it
was never like a beting it was it was
just you got to beat up
you have to beat up kids my move was the
bi that was yeah and this is the other
thing yeah and I'm not saying every mom
is like going to be violent but I'm
saying by and large women are much more
violent than men it's like not even
close I wonder if it's I haven't really
given that any thought but I wonder if
it's just because a man doesn't have to
hit a child to to get the child in
control because he WS depends on the
child but for for generally speaking cuz
he looks imposing and he's scary we a
child looking at me you know I'm skinny
and scy voice I think I think it's
because women yell so often the kids
just block that [__] out but when a man
yells he doesn't do it that often so it
has more weight City builds value I
don't I don't think that would explain
women killing the innocent when so
infants and the elderly I just think
women are more emotional may just get
these flashes of emotion and just can't
control it women are biblically of the
devil that's why Eve was tempted not
Adam and Eve was given paradise and she
said I want more every woman is given
the greatest house with a millionaire
and then they cheat with a nightclub
security guard dude I'm a sweaty
nightclub security guard a $10 an hour
nightclub security guard and these women
would leave their million dooll homes to
run around with a sweaty security guard
that's poor for a couple hours but a
couple the point a couple hours ruins
their marriage that's how evil women are
you can get them millions of dollars and
they want more unless they have a beta
male then they'll stay well it was
always a beta yeah there there you go
you're not going to cheat on
that going back to the there's the Evo
now here's the Evo go ahead going back
to the education and she even mentioned
the over sexualization of kids I I mean
right now I'm seeing indoctrination over
education and I think to blame women for
being teachers for that type of
education I think we should be blaming
our our power you know who's controlling
wait a second who's teaching this
garbage to their kids it's it's not it's
not men who are promoting homosexuality
it is women who are promoting
homosexuality it's the school kids the
teachers who are promoting that garbage
don't think it's our culture and they're
telling the women they let women have
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I need to wait wait wait who who
makes the culture who is the culture
catering to no who are they catering to
who is the culture think they're trying
to distract Society trying to distrct
this is another way that women like
Dodge accountability women are the
culture women transplant the culture
women are the ones that are raising the
kids and on top of that the media is
catering to women and so we always blame
like our poor decisions when really it's
like the everything's catering to the
that's what I'm trying to say is the
media which is predominately ran by men
the government which is predominately
ran by men is catering to women to Indo
what women want exactly because they
know it's going to destruct
they know they're breaking the family
right but I'm saying like Okay so I I
know that if I can get paid to deal
drugs it's not it's not their their
fault for for their being buyers it's
the drug dealers fault for doing it so
if women are doing only fans and doing
that stuff it's your own fault for doing
it I think that's what I'm saying I'm
saying women are the buyers because you
just said media C caters to women so
they're the buyers right so who is
catering Med but I'm saying the women
are the ones buying so like why are you
blaming them for there's a cause and
effect but but I'm saying it's women's
own fault but to solve a problem you
have to stop the cause you can't just
blame the effect you have to solve the
cause and the cause is close the legs
yeah that's what it comes down to close
the damn legs I agree with that I don't
think there you go as long as the legs
are closed have any of these but that's
but that's my point is like we always
push it back on the men some somehow
like both to blame I mean how is it men
are to blame I don't understand if a
woman keeps your legs closed how is a
man to blame now we're talking about sex
I'm talking about education all comes
down to that it all comes down to that
men also have choices and men have
allowed them allowed the women to to go
men have always been pigs it's only when
the women became pigs too that's when
the whole goddamn problem start we just
we just went through the stats only 10%
of women of men have had SE have had
more than one sexual partner in the past
year Well
it speaking culturally speaking men have
allowed this to happen too
86 80 86% of women have kids okay only
60% of men have kids do the math that
tells you everything you need know well
and and the other thing is um most men
had no choice well how did how did men
have a choice in the policies that are
passed in the media like the majority
more women had a choice in this than men
had a choice every just you women
weren't allowed to vote and this is it
you know it doesn't Hallelujah this is
what I was trying to say it doesn't take
a day to to build Rome this is the men's
Choice over time that's what
Rin [__] out what percent of men had a
choice in that decision I think by
letting us vote I guess yeah but that's
that's the point is there was only back
then back then there was only a small
percentage of men that even were
involved in that I mean it happened and
men are the leaders so if men lead the
country and what's going on in the
country then you have to look at the
leader look at the like what are you
talking about what I'm talking about is
that most men had no say in women voting
is that true or not true I think men had
a say since they were leading most men
no did most men have a say in women
voting did most men get to vote on that
I have no idea but that's what I'm
telling the men the men voted in the men
who made those decision most people did
not vote back then that's the point a
small percentage of men made yes that is
the point most men had no say so when
you say oh it's the men that let them do
that I'm saying most men had no say in
that so women had say in the when when
was the 19th Amendment here's what it
was well I'm saying that women did not
have to vote policies that oppressed men
women did not have to vote in po like
women all of the politicians are
catering to women they cannot get
elected without the female vote so I'm
saying that women did not just because
women were paid to leave their families
they didn't have to do it and women
chose to do it and there were far more
women that chose to do that then there
were men that had a choice in those
policies so what about the women that
got knocked up and the father leaves why
why okay that was a choice though like
why did you choose why did you choose to
have a kid outside of marriage that's a
choice I mean yeah that's imoral did you
choose the wrong dude in the first place
to go with I mean so that's still no
fault to the man for not taking care of
his child what happens to women's
intuition women's intuition they always
know everything except they never pick
the right man yeah for a dude if she
went for a dude who was likely to cheat
then that some of the blame Must Fall on
her right yeah it's only again only 10%
of men have multiple sexual partners so
how is it that like we're only picking
the 10% of men that cheat and and
there's far I don't think it's anything
to do with cheating I think it has to do
with absent fatherhood you have you just
said there's I think I looked it up from
my podcast there's 15.4 million single
households and over 81% of them are
females so where is the father why did
they leave that is the question yes they
are 70 to 80% of the time about coming
from a single mom um usually women Drive
the man crazy and I can speak from Facts
because my father committed suicide over
my mother because she drove that's okay
I took therapy people need therapy
however usually the woman is the one
that makes bad choices I put myself in
situations that I regret I put myself in
a situation where a guy tried
impregnating me so I wouldn't leave him
okay I put myself there because you know
I didn't leave so it all goes back to a
woman having a choice to leave but did
you would you say you knew up front that
that dude was likely to be that kind of
guy no you know what so I didn't so
you're saying you're accepting
culpability no you know what
I he was never like that until a year
later when he starts showing signs but I
was a [__] idiot and I still stayed
because I was dumb I was dumb as [__]
I'm like oh he'll get better you got
love bombed he it's called narcissism
but at the same time which is the learn
that at my website it's taking
accountability though you got to take
accountability yeah absolutely I think
both should take accountability no but
I'm saying it's not equal because most
men do not have a say where a lot women
have much more of a say in society than
men in 2023 thanks
feminism most guys like you said most
dudes don't get laid anyway like the dud
down public they're not getting any
action in Miami are they you know what
I'm saying so it's only a very small
percentage you've got this kind of
Leverage I mean I would argue I don't
think you know who's screwing around in
like oh you can tell I have a question
you can
tell you're a really pretty person so
how many guys do you turn down that
approach you um most I mean all of them
there we go you just Pro proed for right
no I'm going to be honest no no I'm in
in Miami and guys don't approach me
first of all so I will say that I've
never I don't get approached do you have
Instagram I do have Instagram do you get
messages on Instagram 100 not from Miami
okay do you do you get messages on
Instagram yeah from men that are trying
to date you no not really there's zero
okay your Instagram pull up your
instagam I'll literally do it wait are
we really doing that yeah
yeah go to the Hest I already checked
this she's going to win I saw her I saw
her stuff she's going to win not though
like zero you're ugly I was looking this
I don't think you're a lesbian cuz all
these women hitting you
up that's what I said
Gary men aren't out there like that I
don't know if that really proves the
point like actually the more attractive
a woman
is outside of Instagram messages the
more the fewer men talk to her let's fix
yeah it's just it's just a fact well but
the point is you're still GNA have more
choices than the average guy the average
guy is at Walmart you know that guy at
Walmart that's the average guy some dude
at Walmart he you don't even notice him
and he's staring at you you know you
know what Rolo said to me Rolo said have
you ever gone through the airport and
looked at people when you go through the
airport Walmart and you look at
everybody in their average yeah like no
homo you're like a seven or eight you're
above a mid at average
you said no I know you get attention
because I know there's a bunch of
message requests from all these insults
that want to bang the [__] out of me and
I leave it
unread they're absolutely right because
all these [__] hit me up they
come I had guys approach me last night
at the bar and I'm like please leave I'm
not interested please leave I'm not
interested guys do not get laid because
they won't [__] stop trying and they
don't take no but isn't it about isn't
it about value as well though because
we're in [__] Miami right there's a
bunch of high [__] value dudes here
and again if you're the Walgreens guy
are you getting any action probably not
it's not it's not just about money it's
about all the other elements so I have a
question who has more choice in dating
men or women women oh please I'm going
to say women yeah okay who has more
Choice when it comes to birth control
men or women women women yeah okay who
has more Choice when it comes to
abortion men or women women yeah who has
more Choice when it comes to child
support men or women women women who has
custody men or women women so who has
more who has who
who is more Choice when it comes to
marriage men or women men no no women
women no you
think Mia Mia Khalifa got married Mia
Khalifa got
married if only if only a guy wanted to
marry her a guy got on his knee and
asked I I I understand that but I'm
saying who we we said we said that what
what comes first in 2023 typically sex
or relationships sex okay so who has
more sexual options men or women women
okay so who has more marriage and
relationship options men or women I
think it's the men how how how would
that how would that work when women have
more sexual options you just acknowledge
that because like we're seeing the rise
and only fans and sex working there's a
difference between these guys wanting to
screw them and these guys wanting to
marry but but how do you but how do
never want in a car with high right
right but how do you how do you get how
do you
get the question the back wait wait how
do you how the
right yes Born Again Catholic virgin
let's go no no but how do you how do you
get in the door if you don't have if sex
is starting wait wait wait if sex is
starting first how do you get in the
door do you think sex is starting first
because females think they need to have
sex with a man to get his attention
first I I think just hook up culture and
I think women could have chosen to be
anything and we've chosen to be [__]
so I think there's something about women
that if all women in society had
basically said right no one's getting no
one's getting any [__] until until put
a ring on it then things will be very
different I agree with that yeah well I
actually I think it's women competing
for the top 10% 20% of men and it's like
no no I'm saying like it's like fives
and sixes are trying to compete they're
not going to get in the door any other
way because again you're say the say
have you're saying the guys have
leverage tell Drake to marry you first
good luck you're saying the guys have
leverage and to some extent they do
because there's the old idea okay so
women are the gay keepers of sex and uh
men are the gay keepers of relationship
because once you're you know you're
screwing with that girl you decide if
you're going to continue things or not
but you've got to have got in the door
in the first place and who's who's
getting through the door well really
it's the at20 rule isn't it it's the top
20 percentile of dudes who are getting
most of the leverage most most men are
swiped on left on dating ABS because
women have the options most of those
guys that you swiped left on probably
swiped right on you and you're like n
not my style all those fishermen you
swipe left on every guy holding a fish
but but out here in the real world so
you have men if they can just pick women
off and have sex with them they still
ultimately they're going to discard them
quickly and they ultimately go back to
what you were saying earlier that they
have their Primal hunting instincts they
want the one that they can't have and
that'll be the girl they marry if they
can catch her the men W the one they
can't have yeah that's there's some
there's some truth in that but I mean
some dudes can't get anybody well
there's there's there's truth in that
even for them and the fact is women have
been convinced that sex positivity is
awesome and there's spreading your legs
for everybody is going to make you happy
it doesn't and it just makes you a
discardable another hole that's all
that's well there's also the five% of
the the the let's talk about the anomaly
here there's also 5% that are lifestyle
people like I said that's an anomaly
that's a very small percentage what is
lifestyle what's that mean they're
[__] swingers they're [__] they're
not whes get paid [__] don't I see so
there's a difference if you're if you're
taking
exactly it's shity work man they're
doing a charitable
service some some some some just really
like [__] I don't think that type of
Charity gets you into heaven what do you
think cira I mean they can try I'm not
I'm not going to say who goes to heaven
and who doesn't you might be swinging
into
hell even but I'll say this even with
the culture and the media cardi B would
make no money if all the said ew I don't
want to follow her I don't like her you
know same with same with lizo like that
that's the point like every chick has a
choice of what they consume and we we
love garbage we love the Kardashians but
I also feel like men I mean
predominately men own the strip clubs
they own the porn sites they own the cam
I mean I'll tell you so if they didn't
own those things and then they didn't
encourage it then because if women
stopped being hoes men would be sexually
frustrated guess I
guess what happens first and the and the
thing is and and the thing I would argue
that was women will take off their
clothes regardless I went to Vegas
chicks are walking around topless
they'll do it for free even if there's
no money you know you know but it's
interesting though because when someone
deals drugs we blame the dealer but when
women are [__] and do sex work we
blame the buyer well you you know you
got to think about book to a pre
preventative
medicine women that are technify
technically classified as quotequote
[__] most likely come from single
mothers I mean I I'm transitioning out
of the adult industry and I came from
poverty and that what got me from the
projects to the hills so if people are
smart and use it as a tool when they
come from a poor family because I signed
my own loans to college you know it it's
a much different perspective because you
don't know how they are they separate
work from real life and you know what
those that can good for them respectable
people to a sense however I'm not done
yet I'm waiting you know you can't judge
people necessarily completely on their
background because you don't know what
their struggle is now however they come
from both parental units both parents
are good earners can send them to
college I see no reason why anyone
should do sex work if they have a strong
Foundation I usually don't well um I
first of all about judging I judge
people I judge pedophiles I judge
murderers are you religious actually not
you're not okay cuz I was going to say
judge why you why do you go to
pedophiles immediately though why is
that the immediate comparison she's
talking about
SE because that's where it leads to
because that's where it leads to that's
where it always leads to Yes it do
spooky music sex if you sexualize people
what it leads to where's your stats
Common Sense pull it up your phone's
right there I don't need to pH I don't
need I I know Common Sense then you're
full of [__] I know that I know what
you're telling people you're telling
you're telling women who are poor to be
whse you're telling women to be who are
poor to be whse that's what you just
said you you're [__] [__] you
don't understand the words that are
coming out of my mouth no one does just
just just just to be clear she didn't
tell women to be [__] and there's no
evidence heard there's no evidence of
swinging leads directly to pedophilia
there's zero [__] evidence of
that class then and and understanding
class you don't
understand I just think you're always
going to be judged by your actions and I
and I know women from single mother
homes that were also poor that didn't
choose to do that I think you're always
going to be judged by your actions in
life like well when you walk 14 hours a
day through Los Angeles after you know
you get your job cut you got to do what
you need to do to survive that in a safe
controlled environment where there's
testing consistently every 14 days but
the men just go work at McDonald's you
know what I mean like it's like there
are options there's options I lost I ran
I lost my job I cleaned houses when he
was like 2 years old I was college
educated I cleaned houses and I didn't
and it was during the housing crisis
when uh people people were losing their
homes and I was like I'm not losing our
home I I hated that and and I did what I
had to do I understand you did what you
had to do I'm not judging you but I'm
going to tell you honestly I'm so sorry
that that's the choice you made because
the trauma documented trauma that comes
from that that leads
to ultimately in a lot of cases and I'm
glad and not your case but poverty heart
disease higher incidences of cancer
um instances of not having your your
instincts go just get damaged to the
point where you you your ability to form
relationships maybe not you maybe you've
been an exception but it is a very dark
path and I'm not telling you this from
judgment I'm telling you like one soul
to
another that it hurts people and it h
and it hurts the customers too it hurts
the customers too you would have anyone
go
I you know what I'm not advocating
people to go into porn okay you know
part of the reason why I got into the
red pill space is to also help me leave
porn and build something better for
myself and use my experiences what I
went through to help people and not
judge people I'm not juding you I
totally feel judged um but that's okay
that's me is that because you don't want
is that because you don't want any
accountability is that why you don't
want to be judged excuse me you don't
want to hold any accountability like
most women I do hold accountability so
why don't you want to be judged because
being Jud that because what she's saying
is incorrect about how I feel and what I
went through if anything all I hear is
how I feel how I feel how I feel I don't
hear logic here you have no logic
because you misunderstood the words that
came out of my mouth originally well
people who have a lot of sex with
different people are bipolar so they
switch up on you um no you're just a
[__] idiot because you misunderstood
what but idiot well then why couldn't
you miss why why did you say that I was
talking about pedophilia then never came
out my mouth when when go ahead man I'm
saying that's not what he was saying
he's a
pedophile were you in Po and Zira no so
there you go so there's no [__]
correlation that's not you didn't say
that's not what I said I mean look let's
let's let's be real I guess I guess my
my um my thought process goes like to
Epstein's Island I mean that's just what
I thought of immediately because like
wouldn't that because I I'd imagine
they'd go younger and younger like the
pants there is trafficking that does
happen you know I I do like to bring
awareness of what it's going through I'm
not encouraging people to get but so
isn't he kind of right then like even in
Epstein's Island it's like the sex work
like judged on their personality not
what they do I think no I me but I I I
think I think you you judge a drug
dealer for dealing drugs like I think
you're judged by your choices you judge
a robber for stealing like yeah on yeah
I I think in life you're Jud by your
actions what why the [__] are we
pretending we're not all judging each
other right now you don't walk down a
dark alleyway see a dude with face
tattoos go oh I'm judgment free you're
judging me right now admit it no it's
true everyone's judgeing everyone it
that's how you that's human nature just
get over it the [__] I don't judge
people I judge how people treat me I
think people subconsciously judge
everyone now whether that's right or not
it's a separate question and what was
the original argument before the PED
jokes what was the argument you guys
were having I don't really get it yeah
what were you guys screaming about about
about you guys even remember original
topic was about how about feminism and a
women having the
choice well no I think I think what's I
think what started it was she was saying
that like because she was from a poorer
background you can't Jud I know you
didn't say that exactly but it sounded
like that and then he and then he he
said bipolar judge people and he started
listing who he judged what did you mean
by bipolar that's where the knife hit on
the podcast you said something bipolar
when when women have a whole bunch of
Partners they become bipolar out of
panic and fear oh just having a whole
bunch of SE
trauma causes mental trauma causes do
any have a psychology degree to actually
put this out as a definition no no I'm
the top numerologist astrologer in the
world so yeah I have my own you don't
have a degree I talked to billionaire
something you'll never do no oh I all
right all right no psych degrees are
crazy they that just makes you crazier I
think I think certain rhetoric sounds
good you know it sounds good to say it
leads to pedophilia it sounds good to
say this is always what happens but I
think there's sometimes a lack of ual
evidence to you do what does it matter
what's that got to do with this no I'm
just curious what kind of work you got
nothing to do nothing because I want to
see where you're coming from so I need
to know what your experiences are to
understand why you believe and what you
believe because because I believe in
logic man it doesn't [__] matter what
for you that's Logic for no no it's
Logic for every [__] human one is
that's logic you presented no [__]
evidence whatsoever except you've talked
to billionaires who gives a [__] dude
actually who gives a [__] you talked to
billionaires know about P absolutely
nothing exact
shut except they sell
it well all right so have you talked
millionaire have you a millionaire have
you talk to a
millionaire have you talked to a
millionaire and he substantiated this
claim uh no I don't I don't need to
because they they tell they tell they
tell me how much money they make off
whes that's it are you what was the
claim you're arguing about I missed it I
don't know he say that he say he leads
directly to
pedophilia well I I would I think even
like what he said not he said he was
judging because the first thing he said
but we were talking about pedophilia
before but he was talking about judg his
point was judg yeah his point was about
judgment but also like like to your
point aren't there direct correlations
with people consuming lots of
pornography I don't think people should
conce it seemed like it was like almost
like a soft spot like you knew it was
true that's why you got so defensive
about
speak into the top but are there not
correlations like maybe I'm just
misinformed but aren't there
correlations between people consuming a
lot of porn and then getting into
pedophilia like a lot I've got no idea
have you that's I mean that's what I've
seen Troy Troy the way Troy the way the
way the way that I would think about it
is if like if porn and sex work
typically goes like for younger women or
like the more like desired I would just
imagine that that industry would go
younger and younger probably in certain
cases but I think and I think and I
think well and I think when there's
instances that come out pretty often of
sex Rings where there's young women
being trafficked especially runaway
teenage like I don't think it's like
unheard of to say that they would try to
like start going younger and younger but
I mean yeah
you're I don't know I don't know let me
tell you what we do at porn sets Okay
it's two forms of government ID you have
to be over 18 there has been instances
where it has slipped through that
someone had fake
documentation okay a legitimate porn
company like brazers Bang Bros all that
other [__] like they want to do
something like that an indie porn
company that's an absolute novice it
could happen I don't condone it I think
it's wrong I think watching too much
porn is wrong I think porn should be for
educational purposes like if you're an
incel and you don't know how to F purpos
educational purposes please go on how do
you go no I want to hear
this difference and sizes no no no I
have a wife I don't I don't need to
watch porn she gives me everything I
need when you were younger you probably
didn't learn oh I mean [__] when I was
18 years old sure I watched some porn on
I I grew up a lot since I asked you if
you watch you said no and then I asked
you again yeah sure when I was 18 so you
did talking about two decades ago what
the [__] were you doing two decades ago
hey I'm right in front of you calm the
roid r Rage that's the first time I've
been accused of that you guys are the
stars of the show but I want to go back
to people men young men who watch porn
they're not on the homepage they always
go to darker [__] and their deviancy
develops that's why they all become
criminals and murderers and Psychopaths
and and freaks you think they're
watching the homepage they're watching
the craziest 10 people Bang Gang
sessions and they're watching black
people having sex and it's crazy okay so
I'm going to just jump in on that
because it you know yes okay you may
have age verification but back to what
Pearl was saying even if an but with an
18-year-old model they will be putting
her in pigtails and a little baby doll
and trying to make her look 13 if she is
if she is underdeveloped and that is
promoting child sexualization I have a
counterargument for that so you say
pigtails and all that other [__] right
don't you think some of this actually
could stop people from committing
pedophilic crimes a so you're making the
oh my God so so we're going we're going
to feed their pilia at home I'm not I'm
just asking the question it's the AI
porn argument we're going to normalize
child porn
argument if you have an AI child like if
they produce CP if they if they produce
CP through AI but it it
decreases encounters is it worth it so
if you have ai porn are going to take
all the whor is going to be out of
business soon no because what happens is
it never it's never
I my way out of it though porn is an
addiction it is never enough so you can
Ai and you can pretend someone's a child
all day long to try to you know you know
soothe their their
inner and but what you're going to end
up doing eventually they want a real one
yeah they're not going to be happy with
their their thing in their hands for the
rest of their life it's a mental illness
just like like gender dysphoria man if
you look at the studies of people who
watch porn they say it's identical to
heroin have you seen those studies it's
like the same addiction like that's
[__] [__] why the [__] would you
watch no yo you're a good looking guy
you don't watch porn I don't watch porn
I there you go there you go I think
porn's [__] I read I'm British I read
Dickens but no the point is this
[Music]
um I like
Shakespeare back no no Juliet was 14 we
got to take that back oh yeah oh my
god um only you would know that but when
you think about when you think about
alcohol for example alcohol is a very
drug but not but exactly but not
everyone becomes an alcoholic actually a
minority of people become an alcoholic
most people could drink safely so is it
not possible that we po billions of
people por is more addictive than
alcohol way more yeah cuz think of the
problem of loneliness you said 10% of
guys are getting action yeah yeah that's
a lonely Market that's way more
addictive than alcohol you know you know
what's interesting and that market uses
alcohol to cope have you no they go to
bars get hold up hold up this 10% [__]
turn turn it sorry
you're doing well in that department I'm
doing well he's doing well I'm assuming
you're doing so this is 100% here I
don't know about this 10% we who WM 10
10% are multiple sexual partners okay so
so like Mar well I looked into that
study for status Network and looks I'm
am
0.001% most attractive man on Earth I'm
up there with that's why the girl I
dated had pictures with um Leonardo
DiCaprio I'm dating the girls Leo knows
we're sharing no
no Logan Paul don't watch this so you're
like Logan Paul you get you gety seconds
but I'm saying the girls the girls the
girls the top one% men are around are
actually around Hollywood Elites isn't
that crazy yeah that you're around
specifically and I'm sure you've been
with a girl that's been with a celebrity
that's so it's Comm no but yeah exactly
but like that's great that's great for
you man and but the majority she was a
total
[__] but the majority of guys aren't
having that experience that's you know
what do you know what's interesting but
majority of you guys are watching porn
and addicted that's the point they're
you you don't watch porn he doesn't
watch porn if you do I swear to God I
don't watch porn men who make it in life
they are not addicted to that [__] well
do you know what's interesting so when
someone's dealing drugs we always blame
the dealer and we almost have empathy
for the addicts a little bit but with
porn it's like our only fans that sort
of thing they don't blame the dealer
they blame the customers that's because
the dealer is a woman I don't know about
that no one's ever shown me sympathy and
I'm a co-
kidil accountability promote that to the
children I I I would argue there's more
empathy for drug addicts than there are
sex addicts that's true that's what I
would argue that's probably true sex
addiction is very frowned upon in
society the lowest of the low misund
drug no one gave a [__] me for good
reason for a good reason yeah yeah no no
drug addiction is we're saying it's more
accepted I'm not even saying accepted
but like empath like empathize like
you'll I don't know like I had a cousin
that was addicted to drugs and like
people would always ask how he was doing
and like every time like we'd always be
trying to like help him like rehab all
that stuff I just don't see the same
thing with a sex addict they're gross
they're this I just think drugs I'm I'm
somewhere in the middle where I'm I'm
only addicted to sex when I have cocaine
so I'm I'm I'm in the hybrid what were
you say just drugs it's it's like that
because drugs are physically detrimental
and porn addiction is more mentally
detrimental so drug logically
spiritually okay interesting unless porn
or well no what's worse have more
sympathy for people that are drug
addicts because if you're on like if
you're addicted to heroin and if you're
addicted to porn the guy on heroin's
most likely going to
pass I think people understand drug
addiction a bit more though I think most
people now get the fact that heroin
highly addicts most people get the fact
that cocaine is addictive most a lot of
people don't really they like porn is
that addictive but even but even my
point is with like the only fans workers
like there's always some oh well it like
the the men like they wouldn't have to
do that if there weren't any men buying
but they never have that same argument
for drug dealers like the point is
there's always going to be a customer
for bad decisions yet always an
immigrant there always an imigrant there
always going to be a customer but yet
like when the men make a decision it
it's blamed on the men but when the
women make a bad decision it's blamed on
the customers so what's the solution do
we chop her head off is that what you're
saying that will be a St you know that
will be you want to go Sharia law you
want to cut women's heads off you hate
women that much I don't think we need to
do that but we can bring some rocks
whoa wow that is abusive of you Gary I
think I think part of it is social shame
is a start and a lot of people cuz a lot
of people but a lot of people get on me
like [__] even even because you say like
hate like you hate women like I get this
a lot but it's like social women flock
really quickly against things that are
like socially shamed so if you don't
have social like right now you know we
we're parading only fans workers we're
parading like like cardi B Nicki minach
so you're getting rewarded for the wrong
decisions um so I'd say a start is not
rewarding the bad I have a question
about the social shaming like when you
social shame someone like do you
consider that they might be like kind of
mentally like hinging on something and
if you like socially shame them you
might push them to Suicide I I think you
socially shame bad decisions and if you
don't want to be socially shame don't
make bad decisions and I think it can
prevent a lot of bad
decisions if somebody is seeing seeing
this is shameful and they haven't
engaged in that yet they will prevent
themselves from doing it it it'll stop
the B so you guys are pretty much saying
you don't give a [__] if someone commit
suicide hold on hold on hold on let me
let me answer this let me answer this in
the 19 uh 40s 1950s if if a woman had a
child out of wedlock she was shamed so
you might say oh wow why are they
shaming someone but what about the kid
how many of these kids grow up in single
mother families and they [__] end up
in poverty and their lives are ruined
hell yeah I'm going to shame the woman I
don't give a damn what happens to her
because the kids are more important you
should shame the parent then for the for
the daughter for allowing the daughter
to get into porn it starts from the
parents ah you mean the single mother
who didn't close your legs um my mom
wasn't a single mother she was married I
wasn't talking to you specifically I'm
talking about in general you know every
situation is different
toor most women who are single mothers
have raised their kids in poverty that's
a fact most most of these um men who are
raised by single mothers 85% of them go
to jail for being rapists do you
understand you guys you're creating
their own problem you guys hate I don't
have kids I'm not the single mom I'm
talking about single mother not you I
said that twice now single moms so like
I said single mothers that have
daughters the daughters are most likely
to be promiscuous because they don't
have a father I'm the daughter that came
from a father of suicide so my mother
didn't have the other option to raise me
so you can't really blame the child
that's now an adult for the decisions
that they're doing because of the mother
allowing her to do personal
responsibility is not dead but didn't
you say your mom drove your dad to Souza
yeah pretty much damn so why you blaming
his father I mean I don't get that that
I'm not blam I'm not blaming the father
did I said I blame the father blame
that's sounds like that's not the words
that came out of my mouth sounds like
that's not what came out of my mouth but
you can't blame anyone for your decision
I know people in very similar situations
that made different decisions it's you
but that's the point like by blaming
your parents it's like you're blaming
somebody else I didn't have anyone in my
family to help my mother raise me it's
situ what about and what about and what
about the people that were in the exact
same situation and didn't do that
there's always somebody in the exact
same situation didn't choose to do that
and that's part of
accountability I would have been able to
go to 35 countries if I wasn't making
all the money exactly your choice it was
your choice some people when they were
in the same position you were decided to
go clean hotels you decide to do
something else and travel the world it's
on you damn but what's the what's what's
what's the prognosis of that though I
mean so she made she made some Life
Choices that maybe now she
feels I'm I'm changing did you not hear
what I said I'm transitioning out of it
but the reason why I did porn is because
if someone like you walked into a head
shop I was working in I sold bongs I
probably would have broke one over your
head for talking me that way so that's
why I do porn what what what think this
this is completely illogical respect my
point is my point is if you weed ain't
violent by the way I'm not violent you
okay okay okay I'm not threatening you
I'm using you as an
example zura Zera zura comes on every
podcast and I'm using you as an example
CU you started yelling at me but I'm
saying you
welcome welcome it Z we want more
intensity more views but Z zura comes on
every podcast he talks about he's like
like on coke all this stuff he doesn't
go around saying don't judge me for it
because part of taking judge me you have
to judge me I'm winning hard and I'm
cheating if you make decisions fine but
that's just what comes with it so and
like you got all those countries you
traveled to so all that misery in your
life you deserved you got the countries
for the misery what are you talking
about I'm [__] happy you said 35
countries right why can't I be happy but
there's a good and a bad to all that why
can't I be happy are you happy you don't
sound happy that's what you're about to
bust the [__] microphone over Gary's
head and he's a Jew you can't do that to
a Jewish guy the only people that aren't
screaming at me right now is this lady
you surprisingly Pearl and Troy that's
cuz we hate women I
noticed at least you take accountability
for it I give you that got I'm not
judging you you keep saying I'm judging
you just cuz I'm speaking to you but to
but to to completely ignore and and
still defend the things you did without
taking
responsibility it's stop I'm saying
that's like stupid [__] to say like it's
pointless just like you talking to me
like you know it's like verbal diarrhea
we just we in Mexican we're out in mexic
we just know what you said like I I
didn't even know you did porn until you
said it you're defending I'm
transitioning out of it like I'm not
what does that mean you're transitioning
out of it it means I'm not doing it and
I'm on to the next chapter of my life
I'm going to school for Real Estate
which is f like that's fine no problem I
use that money to but I'm saying like
you can't get mad at the conclusions
people make from the words that come out
of your mouth I'm not getting mad I I'm
trying to clarify because there's words
that being put into my okay so can I ask
you a question a clarifying question
answer because it seems and correct me
if I'm wrong because I don't want to
upset you it's not that you're upsetting
me are you [__] always like
this no but if you call talk me a little
bit more calmly I can talk a little more
calmly Coke's a wonderful drug I've been
very nice I've been I've been nice to
you up
now you need a bathroom break we got
regroup teams here I'm on the wrong team
I'm the Stoners you got the spoon right
got the key but check it out check it
out you got any
Trend no Trend no Trend but check it out
there is nothing personal you were
attacking her on right correct you're
objective what about you Gary oh I was
definitely being personal but but but
just just to
play I'll definitely be personal 100
accountability but just to play Devil's
Advocate do you do you actually give a
[__] if people judge you or not she
shouldn't she shouldn't do you give a
[__] I really don't but what I do judge
is when people misc constru my words
you're judging so clarify you have said
a lot of EX flat out excuses and reasons
for the life you chose for the life you
chose and you defended it and you blamed
your mother and I'm so sorry about your
father blaming my mom I'm saying where I
came from and he said something about
blaming the single mom and I'm like yeah
but you did blame your circumstances and
your mother and your father for killing
himself for your choices and you defend
it and you justify it over and over you
have here we've got the tape what cool
so when I say it seems that you're
justifying and defending this life you
come at me like on with the you don't
know me like that's ridiculous I mean
technically I'm like [__] suck to your
shoe just like your [__] stuck to my
shoe so what does it even matter about
you know what cuz you know what honey
you're not the only one I'm not your
honey oh you're so stupid stop saying
things oh my God you know what great
cast I love this God I'm going to tell
you I used to be a backup dancer for the
Devil Himself and you know what I
learned I know a lost soul when I see
one I'm not lost you are lost as [__]
your I say something else I'm not L you
are [__] lost yeah you need to be
saved and I'm not and I'm not trying to
judge you I just know a lost soul and oh
my God you are in so much trouble you
are so troubled no oh sweetie I I am
going to pray for you and myself I don't
need your pray don't waste you do need
my prayer don't waste your time waste
your time your time that I will give you
a fist bup for I can't even do no no
listen first of all hey hey hey woman
Jesus loves you but why are you talking
about I'm leaving porn if there's no
shame stay if there's no why are you
trying to leave because you know what
I'm tired of the people in it I come the
demons I'm you know what I'm actually a
very happy person and I go to set want
put that to a vote want to see what
everyone here thinks I really don't give
a [__] exactly
is reality and if you go through
everyone here we don't think you're
happy as a matter of fact we think
you're probably miserable but you have
some money so I I respect
that in the Hills though she's in the
Hills miserable she went to mikos how
could she not be happy it depends how
you def you know you guys are looking
superficially she's coming to podcast
she's getting angry she's getting you
know whatever because everyone gets gets
he everyone gets heated on these things
it's fine but you know I was out I was
out with you the other night you've got
a strong group of very good friends she
didn't threaten to bottle your head with
glass like she did Gary for
I doubt he was talking to her I was that
as an example no no you're you're for
podcasting you're very entertaining but
you're saying she's not troubled she's
the first 10 minutes threatened to
bottle like Jew no I'm just saying about
to see a world class DJ sheas I'm not
say I'm not
say this Hamas here holy [__] no I'm not
saying she's not trouble she's
definitely trouble but what I'm saying
is he's in trouble he's in the G what
I'm saying is I was I've seen you with
you you've got very strong friendships
you've got very good relationships with
your family you've got you know you
there's people that you've known for
many many years who really care about
you you've got great B with those people
I don't see you person knowing you a bit
personally I don't see you as being this
this horrendously miserable person you
saw how happy I was there how many
people hugged me and love Meely he just
told you you were troubled and you
didn't say no I said she was troubled
not troubled she's troubled because she
kicks off with people like English
accent she couldn't understand but how
how can you sit there and say a porn
star hasn't gone through it like I've
met all the porn stars they all say they
had a trouble past even you said that oh
yeah how are you going to take away all
your trauma and say no I had rainbows
and [__] bunny rabbits say I had a
troubled past that's why I'm a porn star
because you know what there there's a
difference between I was a drug dealer
cuz I had a troubled past now you have
to own yours say you're a porn star CU
of trauma I I did porn cuz I wanted
money but she's saying that and you guys
are arguing with her that she's not
taking account accountability so I think
we should take accountability she said
you can't judge it now that I got 25
trips and I live in the Hills you can't
judge it she got into that she said
something and you said she's not taking
accountability Tak taking accountability
is accepting the Judgment that comes
with po decisions it's not shaming
everybody for for judging you that's
what comes with it if I if I say I'm a
cokehead and everyone judges me I mean
and I can either argue I can either
argue with everyone and say stop it stop
it stop it or I could say okay she was
taking accountability but she said this
is my struggled past and this is why I
led into this future no that's just
that's she's she's right you're
confusing storytelling with
accountability she told the story but
she blamed her past for her AC that was
after she threatened to bottle
GE my point is if we look at the
majority of sex workers don't they have
a troubled past yeah they all cut
themselves okay so don't you think we
should be looking at the troubled past
yeah it's called the single mother yeah
so the Chastity Bel that's what it all
accountability she's also saying she has
a trouble pass taking accountability
isn't giving an excuse right
after well I also think there's a
difference between judging and assuming
like you know someone which people are
assuming like they know me when they
don't I I'm not saying no one's saying
they know you they just know the choices
you made what's your
birthday he he does say you don't know
you so basic basically Gary he how he
made millions and millions of dollars is
he does numerology and astrology off a
birthday
I don't know if you've seen his content
off your birthday he can tell you a lot
about you and this is how he does sports
betting about about zodiac signs well
not all those all those channels on
YouTube they don't make money they're
all [__] but he does sports betting
so he'll know the quarterback's birthday
and stuff so it's they're asking your
birthday so he can read your sign it's
like people pay him thousands of dollars
for these reads you can have one for
free yeah do
it he didn't even show me the respect of
fist pumping so I'm not going to give
them the respect no I'm
curious not me I'll tell you you're a
nine you're going to turn out to be a
nine I I will tell you after the show to
give you the respect cuz you haven't
done much to I'm so curious though it's
to make me you
fist let's go I tried making it right
with him he refused it so you know what
he doesn't deserve that respect je they
can't shake a woman's hand let's
question them let me ask you a question
though um you said that you're not going
to you're like transitioning from porn
you don't want to do it anymore right
just a few let me let me ask you this
would would you think it's okay to shame
women who are younger not to do porn no
I think you should help them for a
better path versus shaming them just
like how you coddle a drug dealer to
rehab and stuff what more help do we
need we have government met benefits
child support Alamo like what more help
do we need who is codling toam a bunch
of we have a bunch of well then women
should stay with the men they pick to
make children
with so that's back on theen I don't is
there a statistic on that how many women
leave compared to men 70 to 80% 80% yeah
you guys are evil don't ask for
statistics bro you don't want statistics
with these women topic every static
makes you some one out of three women
has had an abortion one out of three
women has an STD 90% of women have been
on birth control at some point in their
life the ad average number of sexual
partners ranges somewhere between five
and 25 and over five bodies you have a
25% chance of a happy marriage the stats
are not on our side when it comes to
decision- making and making choices that
benefit the family and not us for
whatever reason women are very selfish
we leave 70 to 80% of the time and one
of the number one reasons for divorce
are Financial when women live when women
win the lottery they tend to leave when
men win the lottery they tend to stay he
just made a point that most most of
these single mothers are uh raising
children in low income so I think that
just contradicts what you're saying that
they're leaving for financial reasons
yes because they because no no you're
they are paid to leave they are given
child support and alimony that's very
and the father doesn't have to do
anything he gets the kid for the weekend
and he's the cool guy always not always
because they'll deny access to the kid
but I think a lot of the reason the
women are leaving is not because of
money necessarily it's cuz they're bored
and they want the next bright shiny
thing you know they see the hot guy on
Instagram they're like oh my husband wom
women are more like to divorce um if
they get a promotion at work again
listen to what I just said when women
win the lottery they leave when women
get to the choice to leave they unless
they hit this Lottery then they stay but
women are evil they're imagine if I
cheated on my wife with Beyonce I go
back to my wife if you cheated on me
with Jay-Z you'll never come back to me
and you'll make me a racist I'll hate
black men forever you when women y when
women upgrade they never come home when
they up that's why they you blame them
for upgrad upgrading here wait wait wait
wait repeat that well you why would you
want to be with her if she's no no no no
repeat what you just said like if yeah
if women upgrade why would they go
back you just you just said can you
blame them that was the words you used
you said can you blame them yes blame
the [__] like how you can blame the the
leader that's supposed to lead the
family why is the home so okay I have I
have a question have a question family
why do women deserve top G when a third
of them have had an abortion of the
women do not give men Authority women
will [__] and moan about men leading
but they don't follow so then that that
means men aren't leading that
means no it doesn't that's the point no
it doesn't you automatically are blaming
the men you cannot you cannot autopilot
you're on CNN autopilot you cannot lead
you cannot lead a woman that doesn't
want to follow
generational let me let me let me let me
use this in an employee relationship if
I say blessing set up the camera he says
no I say blessing set up the camera he
says no what what else the [__] am I
supposed to do put a gun to his head
that's how a lot of men it's not what
you said it's the way you said say
better to yeah and and and the other
thing is if if me if if me and Troy are
in a contract and I'm PA to leave the
contract and he loses everything in that
contract um I'm sorry but he's always
going to be trying to make me happy and
that's modern marriage the way that the
legal system is set up it it affects the
way that men and women interact with
each other and Pa makes a really good
point because you respect is only is is
given by is granted by the woman and
when that respect is lost you know it
doesn't matter if he's trying to lead
and be the Super Alpha she's not going
to [__] take it serious women women
get bored very quickly was Tom was Tom
Brady not a leader yeah I mean I I don't
know I don't know what he
was okay I'm asking what what did Tom
Brady do wrong can I be honest I don't
really know much okay what did Donald
Trump is Donald is Donald Trump a leader
wait is Donald is Donald Trump okay he's
been married three times Tom Brady got
divorced all of these high status High
net worth men that have literally LED
Nations have been divor Trump get left
or did he leave Donald Trump left he
left no 80% statistic that women leave
so 80% chance you're wrong men don't
even leave women we just collect new
ones I'm serious if if my girlfriend if
my girlfriend did something horrible to
me I'm not going to cheat and leave her
I'll just collect a new girl I'll cheat
and I'll have a second girl but cheating
is of the devil you're gonna you
cheating is gay by the way because you
know why men who cheat men who cheat
they have infinite they go from one girl
to 5 to 10 cuz it's a deviancy their
fetish is deviancy and there's nothing
more deviant than having sex with a man
so men who cheat actually become gay
over time straight men stay with one
woman till they die so would you just if
you were with a woman would you say to
her up front listen I'm not always going
to be monogamous or would you get into a
monog relationship never in my life I've
been in two long terms yeah the easiest
thing on earth is to not cheat you just
play Xbox at home bro the easiest thing
on earth bro I don't know how people
think cheating is like a thing if if
you're cheating on your girl she's ugly
that's the
truth I've always look after two years
I'll stare at my girlfriend I'll be like
yo she's so hot yeah but but again if
she's ugly maybe you cheat I don't know
no but there no there are dudes who come
on these podcasts like I've heard even
the Tates were talking about this stuff
whereby they would say well look you
know men are not naturally monogamous so
therefore look at if we're going to if
we're on let's go by the all right you
want to go by the natural argument
Andrew takes dumb ass argument it's
natural to it's natural to rape it's
natural to kill it's natural for me to
strangle her and bring her to my house
if you go by a natural argument I can
start killing all the handicapped
wheelchair people cuz they're not
contributing natural argument is
horrible that's why we go back to the B
men men are naturally I would argue men
are naturally benevolent towards women
yes I would argue because if they wanted
to all of the men could get together and
put us in cages and make us sex slaves
and instead of doing that they gave us
all of rights that we wanted they're
just doing it to Children instead who
who the sex trafficking what are you
talking about they are putting children
and women in is that okay is that the
majority of men no listen majority of
men is what you see in in Walmart that's
majority of men and you know why men are
better than women the emotional ones are
already in prison but emotional women
don't get locked up so there's a lot of
crazy [__] out there like when you
see a dude at Walmart he's just a
standup dude right I I see like respect
for a generational brainwashing you you
damn yes destroy her I was raised in
time she's going to make it easier for
me to date you the program CNN fake news
I was raised in a time where we were not
taught to hate men men were but you know
the patriarchy were our protectors our
providers our fathers our brothers our
cousins our friends yes young women
today are taught that you can't get
ahead because men are holding you down
men are holding you back and everything
you have just every I'm listening very
very intently and everything you have
just said was everything was men's fault
in the face of a hundred valid
statistics from Pearl you still said but
the
men and and even here we're talking
about you know just now you said well
what it's the men putting the women and
the children in the cages you're talking
about deviant like a small group it it's
this this automatic
indoctrination that has happened to you
where you automatically jump to it's the
man's fault and that is so [__]
troubling been no I've been saying this
whole time that men should be leaders
and I'm not blaming men at all I'm
blaming both I'm blaming the family unit
I'm blaming this is not generational
whatever you're saying brainwashing this
is me saying togetherness this is yin
and yang have I have a question I have a
question I have a question I have a
question I have a question okay so me
I'm out here me and Troy we get married
whatever and I say now we're together 10
years and I say two kids and I say sorry
Troy gotta go yeah yeah okay now I say
Sorry's sorry we're just you're you're
here today so now now I say I say sorry
Troy I gotta
bounce what is he supposed to do no no
no no but I but I'm asking you what did
he do wrong leadership wise if I say
Troy sorry I watched e Pray Love last
week I got to go I think that's
not lead this
situation people's stresses and
struggles and problems are not e pre
love they're actual problems people are
going through things why do why do why
do women why do why do women divorce
when they win the lottery why do women
divorce when they win the lottery the
why do women why do women divorce when
they win the lottery no were you I'm
giving you I'm answer my question why do
women divorce when they win the lottery
why do women divorce when they get a
promotion at work why cuz they they
clearly didn't want to be with him why
exactly and that's the point because
women care more about what they want
than the actual family and there's
nothing are emotional you're this is
logic you're now saying women uh are
like acting with Logic No women are
emotional so they that's not what I'm
saying at all if they win the lottery
and then they leave that's a logical
move that's not an emotional wait wait
wait wait wait wait what how no how was
it no no I want you explain that because
you're just saying she doesn't need the
man because she has money and she
doesn't okay so let me get this straight
log okay okay so it's logical to put
your kid in a situation where they're
more likely to be in a mental
institution more likely to run away from
home more likely to be a rapist and more
likely to be a criminal that's
logical
selfishness what what that's now
selfishness they're not is the point can
men cannot do any men cannot do anything
to lead selfish women that do not want
to be led but we're only talking about
women leaving men men leave because the
majority of the time women leave can I
ask a question do you think it's fair to
say that women and also maybe men but
women are less Keen to work through
difficult times now than perhaps they
were in the past she's an American she
doesn't know what Keen means all right
they're not enthus they're not they're
not willing to work through CU
relationships have ups and downs right
so it's good at the beginning then it
dips a bit then it maybe it gets a bit
better whatever you go through tough
times say he loses his job whatever do
you think it's fair to say that today
women are less likely to tolerate Point
hell she would divorce me over Ikea
furniture bro they can't do [__] that's
not true at all I that's his point that
women are more yeah he's right you're
wrong you have nothing I would 100% stay
in my marriage and work through my
marriage that's the whole point of
building and growing said that every
woman on earth said what you said oh
I'll stay I'll work through it but the
studies are not on your side you're evil
you're P well I mean I guess yeah I
haven't met these I I I want to know I
just I want to I want to do a role
playing exercise the only reason why a
woman should ever leave is if she's
being physically abused other than that
be a woman and try to I'm advocating for
the the man who how
many anyways so I want to do an exercise
cuz she talked about this amazing
leadership that we need know would you
leave if your husband cheated um
honestly it really no I wouldn't cuz
I've been Che
on what a li you Chang your you can look
in your eyes and tell you're lying
you're it on and i' said would I
struggle through it and would I be sad
yeah absolutely I want to move on to an
exercise I really want I want that guy
why aren't you with that guy right now
he was abusive like physically yeah duck
kiding did you hit him first no here's
the thing if he if if he's cheating ask
if he would share I how solve the
problems okay I want to I want to do an
exercise with the guys okay so I keep
hearing from the wom never h a woman in
my life what you talking about wait wait
okay keep hearing wait wait wa wait I
wanna I wanna I want to do an exercise
because I keep hearing about this poor
leadership right so I want to do a role
playing we're married okay and I say I'm
just I got to bounce
and I'm taking the kids and your money
and everything from you how do you
respond you're taking the kids the money
and everything yeah yeah I'm also gonna
get a restraining order and I'm gonna
I'm gonna label you as an abuser well
yes I'm probably just moving to
like no no please lead lead me lead me I
would live up to the title you give me
start beating the [__] out of you who's
the abuser yes yes anyway how would you
could you please leave just go fishing
um I think I'd be a I think I'd become a
murderer you'd be you'd be a Mur that
happens a lot actually that's pretty
common Troy lead me please lead me you
know what it's an imposs it's it's an
impossible question isn't it because you
can't because this happened to my friend
in London right be a better leader
please just leave better don't leave
don't leave you
[__] no I'm going I'm
going but I want I want your cash please
not getting my cash you are don't
leaveing no no yes abuse abuse what
about reverse psychology leave [__] now
she's staying I know these
women no but do you hear what she's
saying she's making fun of you that you
can't lead better you're getting
humiliated live on national TV I don't
think I'm getting invol okay well then
maybe say it the microphone woman come
on you're going to
rewatch tell her she needs to talk to
the microphone she's killing though she
would never date a guy who makes money
than her also guys never ever ever never
ever nothing against you but I'm just
going to say this never ever ever date a
woman that says she has an abusive
ex-boyfriend because you will be the
next one you will be the next one that
she calls abusive swear to God do not do
it I don't know if it's her I'm saying
don't ever
do this has just happened to a guy
friend that I know literally this chick
oh my ex was abusive okay you know who
she's calling Abus who who she's calling
abusive next okay well I've dated two
guys after him and I didn't call him I
didn't I just said what what did I start
it by what did I start it by not about
you no no no it's really interesting
that you say that because you know what
like I really recommend therapy and I
really recommend being single until you
are healed because a lot of these women
that leave abusive relationships hop
right into the next one and they don't
even fix themselves and so they [__] up
the next guy we're right there waiting
for them no it's not even that what do
you consider abusive it's just hitting
you or you want to see my jaw and how it
comes unhinged okay so someone hits you
okay I got my face J wait so I have a
question so both of you were
abused excuse me why did that happen
because he was taking
drugs you shouldn't be around drug addi
I didn't know he was taking drugs and
when I found out he was taking drugs he
broke my phone every time I tried to
leave so I just so you guys were these
like perfect angels being amazing and
perfect and I never said I was perfect
he just okay I'm I'm still at at 16 you
were this perfect angel that did nothing
wrong oh yeah three season sport athlete
okay who
cares I my [__] together I had my [__]
together it doesn't matter I'm asking
I'm asking you were I'm asking she had a
40% free throw
range absolutely it doesn't matter the
girl that I know I'm thinking of she did
she was an athlete too who cares okay so
you were this perfect angel did nothing
at all they weren't Fighters you got to
hit him back right if he hits you you
tase him you take a one step higher
there's still submissive females out
there just so you
know is she just a good girl that just
got abused all right listen it doesn't
start with a punch in the face it's not
like oh honey can I take you out on our
first date and we're going to go out and
then you get a punch in the face it is
it is gradual it's mock ellan you you
have tiny little cuts that happen little
words that you know something he'll say
something really shitty and you go uh I
didn't like that and he'll love vomb you
and tell you he's sorry and
progressively over months it gets worse
and worse until it leads up to the punch
in the face and for some women it leads
up to them dying so it isn't as simple
it happens slowly and you become
psychologically wom are agree to that
but but my whole my whole thing is women
women are verbally abusive too and I I
find it very rare I find it very most
women that say that claim abuse are
pretty argumentative and and I find it
very rare that they just did nothing and
we're perfect angels that were just hit
I find that there is an anomaly of that
but I would agree you are somewhat right
about that there is an an and women and
women I and I've interviewed women that
work in abuse shelters and they'll say
the same thing women love to play the
victim and never talk about their part
ever hold on let me say in in Russia uh
President Putin actually allowed
domestic violence it's not illegal
anymore that's true and the divorce rate
went what way down after that that's all
I'm saying yeah but is that necessarily
a good thing if women are getting
smacked around and okay but I'll tell
you I'll tell you I'll actually I'll
actually break this down I'll tell you
that I'll tell you that the problem with
abuse so one one thing is you actually
you don't need any evidence to file a
restraining order against anyone because
you go to Family Court Family Court is
not based on evidence it's based on a
balance of probabilities meaning if you
cry to a judge you you can get a
restraining order second thing and same
with an abuse um and same with um
claiming that a guy abused you like in
divorce court child custody court second
problem you get is that um they've
expanded the definition of abuse so
abuse used to just be a man hitting a
woman but they've expanded it and added
an emotional abuse Financial abuse yeah
and and that's the problem what
feminists do
fin you you yeah you said something I
don't like and so they expanded that
coercive control thing now in the UK
Cove control and so what happens is
feminists use these institutions against
men now there are women that were
actually abused yes we acknowledge that
yes but even but yeah we know we know
but I I've even I've even I've even what
is emo abuse That's So and I've talked
to women that that like um Erin pizzy
the first woman that founded the an
abuse shelter in England right um she
says herself that most abuse is mutual
most people are hitting each other most
women are not these perfect angels that
did nothing wrong but you had a story
about you were telling me a story about
a woman that you know who was who had
fabricating something actually this this
is a friend I had in the UK cuz I used
to live there myself um I met this
couple uh back in 2013 2014 they
recently split over the
winter um the woman is at fault at this
because you know she's been getting
crazy she's been on
drugs no she's been [__] somebody
else when the man was monogamous and so
when the man found out and wanted to
kick her out the woman started hitting
herself
and then she filed domestic violence
charges my friend went to jail for a
week now she's saying that he's like
cyber stalking her doing this and that
and you guys live in UK so you know how
those laws are like and so now he's
actually going to the Crown Court over
cyber stalking and domestic violence
when she was stalking him and she was
the one that abused him this why you
need stones say it again say it again we
I'm going say this they're evil but that
one is fine cuz listen if if my
girlfriend goes to as far as to punch
herself in the face 10 times to put me
in jail I think we're both
winning so this [__] deserves
[Music]
that oh my [__] god that's a terrible
story and it does happen if I was a guy
I would record everything I would have
ring cameras like all over my godamn
record everything except sex don't
record
everything it's consensual make sure
it's consensual have that [__] on video
not video audio record AUD I am so happy
I got married 20 years ago and I don't
deal with any of this nonsense [__]
this shit's crazy man this shit's crazy
audio recording and video recording is
legal with the person's consent but that
also varies state by state within the in
the union and also country the every
individual country's law I'd rather risk
the audio recording I'd rather risk
getting trouble it's best to it's best
to risk it because you know what you got
her consenting so she's like he didn't
grape me you know what I mean right you
know what oh my gosh I heard this story
oh my God this is so crazy this um there
was a a case where they he had a Tinder
date right and he brought her back to
his apartment and she got drunk and fell
off the balcony now
exactly and and he got so lucky because
he was recording everything and she
really did get drunk and fall off the
balcony but imagine if he didn't record
that he would be done done fck I heard
about cuz she like cuz cuz the thing is
they were kind of fighting cuz she would
she refused to leave tell he was telling
her to get out and she wouldn't go if he
didn't record in the house it would have
been 100 years imagine a 100 years in
your cell saying I didn't even get to
push the
[__] even got a little out that
one you got to record everything though
yeah if I was a do it's a [__]
mindfield out there now isn't it really
is I mean Jesus I know they need to make
like an hour you people need numerology
and astrology in your lives that way you
won't get divorced forget about these
priests these imams and these rabbis
numerology and astrology okay can we
please hear your birthday please for me
please I lost so hard like Zer had a
tear come out I said i' make the
pornstar cry didn't I funny you're
you're Mak you know making me cry from
laughing is a great and thank you for
that yeah yeah no so my birthday wasn't
my intention my birthday is the same day
as Albert Einstein 's birthday 199 314
yeah P yeah 314 so people born exactly
you knew he said he said it off top five
all five so again remember we're on the
yacht and all those girls were five so
you're born on the 14th one and four is
five five is number of sexuality sex
first vow e e is the fifth letter
reproduction first vow e again so you're
doing basically in a sense what you're
supposed to but you basically fell for
the Trap so you're you're basically a
failed reincarnation you're going to
have to do this [__] all over again
could you just so I'm a 5'2 I'm a 5
she's also you're also 1992 right 92 you
said so she's an 11 life path too you're
11 she she's emotional as hell she's
emotional you could have done so much
better than doing this stuff you could
have been famous you really could have
you didn't need to do this you did not
need to do this she's an 11 she so
basically CU she's born on the 14th
that's a very sexual number that's a
very attractive number so that's
basically where it comes from but her
total number traveled she's went to 35
countries fives are always TR are always
traveling too and stuff like that so
hits her like you're also probably made
a lot of bad choices because you feel
sorry for people and you want to try to
mold them and help them and things like
that and that's backfired a lot for you
actually you know what the only thing
that backfired on me in molding and
helping was helping my family when they
never appreciated it you still did it
it's still I did it because you know
what I'm a compassionate loving human
being
and I have a soul you have to help you
have to help yourself before you can
help others H yeah I understand
that 11 is a predictor of success
right or a school shooter it's one or
the other so like forance a lot of
people let me just go through the list
Joe Rogan born on the 11th Aiden Ross
born on the 11th Barack Obama's in 11th
McGregor is 11 so a lot of people who
have 11 have Charisma you didn't have to
do this you would have found another way
yeah that's what I'm telling you you
could have been something on radio said
yet okay so so so okay what part not yet
I'm I'm out of it I'm on my way out of
it do you not hear cuz you know honestly
I got into it and I stayed in it because
I was still wanted to know what I wanted
to do I did not like my internship I was
doing web design interactive media and
Digital Arts I didn't like coding
brushed it in that no you know what the
thing is 11 tell you would have found a
husband who would have married you and
knocked you up I have a catism do you
know how that's light looking at a
computer screen were you a nurse what
does it matter no no it matters with
everything else to do find something
else to do of course I solved my
problems I grew up broke my dad was an
immigrant from the Soviet Union I grew
up broke I made it myself because we're
in a capitalistic country and if you
work hard look how you're yelling at
women they don't respect women over
there they don't respect them here here
your birthday let's see if you can be
accurate with her 19274 1974
yeah 74 19 19th of February 19th of
February 1974 okay he's a tiger like T
yeah tiger like so so basically alpha
male masculine all that good stuff he is
you know that's that's basically where
now hold on what's his number what's his
life tiger he's a four oh Law and Order
you don't break the law you haven't brok
the law a little bit he
he's he manages he manages and he's very
uh disciplined and he basically the one
thing you have to watch out for is two
fours workhorses right yeah he he he's a
hard worker but he's more of a tiger and
that basically means his way of living
life is a little bit different you can
be the guy who can have like four or
five [__] on the side you can do that
other guys cannot he's right isn't it
he's right he's right okay I'm so just
like T just just like t wait so wait so
the five I used to think he caters the
advice to like looking at you but he's
gave that same thing to someone else
who's a tiger like he says that to all
of them not just you so he didn't look
at you and say and I do my own Stu I am
getting out of porn and that's why I'm
like upset that everybody's attacking me
when do what you have to do what you
you're an 11 you could win anywhere what
you have to dud hold on what you have to
do is basically look in the camera and
tell young girls do not do this this is
[__] me up do not be like me this is
what you need and yes you got a bag can
do I I said that already I said I don't
recommend women getting into supp porn
no you have to fight and nail and save
the souls save the souls that were the
young people you can actually you can
save your younger self can I say what
I'm doing with my podcast my podcast is
meant to help women not get into sex
work or help women get out of sex work
but the one thing you have to do is
accept accountability don't say I didn't
I already
know that's what you've been doing here
You' been saying my mother was poor my
dad wasn't
let's go back to what the topics were
okay originally about single mothers
with daughters that become
promiscuous okay I'm saying I am a
statistic of
that okay I already took accountability
for it baby boy not the way I've been
hearing you talk here well you also
confused what I said and put pedophilia
on my mou I I mean listen man you are
woman and women support homosexuals and
pedophiles at a much greater rate than
men hold on Gary Gary when you said you
know your Buddhist mysticism you said
she failed he's Buddhist no no but I'm
just calling I'm calling it I'm call I'm
not Buddhist no no I'm just I'm talking
[__] but check it out you said she
failed her reincarnation can she do
anything to fix it now or she to save
different Souls that's but she's [__]
for doing many years I personally
believe she's [__] yeah and but listen
Catholic you don't believe know I don't
believe in that reincarnation I wonder
Jesus is not the doorman in heaven
anymore you are when did that happen um
I'm not
I'm not a religious
person let's just let's just say for
argument sake right she's making this
change in her life she's going to do
this podcast she's going to try and help
help people isn't that you're talking
about saving Souls what if she tries to
do that I believe that there is there's
no Karma and there's bad karma if you do
good things nothing good is GNA come
back to you your reward is not getting
punished with Bad Karma you do bad
things bad things come back to you but
you do nothing nothing bad comes back to
you so I don't believe she's going to
get rewarded for doing what she's doing
but I do believe she can still make a
difference and save other women from the
trauma she went through in life and I
and I believe that's that's a that's a
great goal to do you're half right
opinions are like
[__] he's the most rare number you
can get at 33 you're half right it she
it is it would be really cool if you can
help other young women totally but but
that doesn't that but you are not
automatically relegated to uh
reincarnation and the hell of doing this
over and over again there is a way out
of this there is a
way there is a way out of that I it's
not about religion it's not about Rel
another life she would have to come back
and live another life in order to okay
uh you should stay in Miami cuz Miami
was founded in a monkey year America was
founded 1776 you're the monkey and
you're found born 1992 the year of the
monkey so you'd have most your success
in this place right here and monkeys
play games yes they do she's going to
get distracted a lot yes they do that's
F that's fascinating stuff how do you
know so so where should I be I'm based
in London is that a good place um no
London sucks
you we agree on that but I'm saying
since you're on social media you should
be out here you would do better in
London than you would in America because
America is a monkey Country and this
you're a tiger this the this is the same
reason Tate hates America because he's
it's a monkey country and he's a tiger
but T still it doesn't work he doesn't
come here he hates this no he doesn't
wait he doesn't know and he knows this
he knows this information I love America
you're that's why you're the craziest
thing I ever saw Andrew I'm tell from an
energetic standpoint that is why no from
an energetic standpoint not an opinion
standpoint not what you think from an
energetic standpoint that is 100% I'm in
America because I've seen the world and
I appreciate this country more than you
even know my God I love
america24 and who you voting for Donald
Trump okay go now now you can get that
yes wait wait but here's the the
craziest part about Gary is there's I
don't know if it's a tweet or something
Andrew Tate's father so when I met his
son he made sure he had sex with his
wife on certain dates so he could get
the best numbers for his son his son is
this beautiful genius the top of his
class and he said to his son the son
does the math in his head so he knew my
life path and everything and he said to
his son doesn't zurka look like he said
zurka is a dog like zodiac dog and his
son's like no awkward you know how kids
are awkward now his son's very cool he's
like yeah he looks like one as in like
they have certain faces and stuff so he
gets this stuff but I'm like when I saw
his son I started believing this [__]
then he showed me andu Tate's dad he
wrote a tweet saying 2011 he wrot he he
he timed Andrew's birthday and he said
this is going to be one of the most
powerful Tigers the world ever sees what
was that tweet it was 2011 he said
Andrew Tate is a tiger and now he's also
a snake and he said no one seen this
combination or something like that and
which is weird his dad is CIA linguist
genius but he's CIA so all the CIA guys
know what he knows well I doubt that and
he's a chess master I've taught plenty
of CIA guys this but he's the rarest
number he's he's Hitler's number it's a
poly mouth genius you're 33 that's
Hitler Hitler was a 33 you why can't you
say Einstein why can't you say one of
the rape Brothers cuz Einstein's Jewish
I share his birthday with them we're
going to go for the Catholic yes you do
he wasn't a cathol when it comes to my
life I'm very different for everyone
else uh I study studying numerology in
2001 and I saw that the royal family
kept having uh Prince William and all
these other Royal members like uh the
the King right now um they're all 11s
they're all 11 life paths and I'm like
okay this is interesting so they're
obviously having C-sections on certain
days so I basically follow the elite he
told his wife to have a C-section he cut
her off 100% they're doing it
deliberately 100% And that I did deliber
too like I told my wife we're having
kids on this day and this day I timed it
out perfectly Within two weeks and we
had the C-section then and they even do
world events like 911 they'll choose
emotional frequency numbers or when
China wanted money in 2008 at 8:00 p.m.
on the 8th day what was it uh China
started the Olympic Games on 88 2008 the
money number you you have sex with a
girl who's born on E you make money a
28th is wealth real money R questioning
Pearl why is this so H you trying to get
everybody naked or something why are we
wa it is hot in here
um blessing didn't you turn off
the the audio heat up
in no hold on I had to crack a joke to
that Troy you could have been a good cop
cuz you're a four both of you could have
been good cops you know that structured
could have been a good investigator now
you destroyed him [__] numerology she's
a woman it doesn't count he could have
been a good cop he's a man and a four
actually I could have been a detective
like no you should have been a lawyer
you're good at
arguing
but you said I don't break the law but I
have broken the law some minor things in
the you of all your friends are the most
likely to get caught if you [__] up
break I'm most lik to get caught yeah
that that nobody knows why but fours are
damag four is the number of Law and
Order so basically you like Donald Trump
is born on the four you're like a magnet
for police so if you do anything wrong
you have to be be very very
careful real I yeah yeah yeah no and and
can I Le no
no oh it's sit down sh so you got to be
careful then basically I'm just careful
with what leaks out because you have to
understand every numerologist in the
world follows me if I say something it
becomes a law so I don't I'm know I
don't want to help them you know there
there's certain information we have that
if we worked with you guys you guys are
our co-workers we would abuse exploit
your numbers the [__] we know that's why
he doesn't let me leak it we could
literally milk every penny from you and
lock you out of contracts it's very e
know some of this [__] is it just
forgive my for especially these numbers
yeah forgive my ignorance but is it so
you've you've gone off the birth dat and
you you've given us these Topline things
is there a I'm assuming there's a lot
more to a
[__] this is this is very surface stuff
for a podcast he said to me Zira we're
going to work together this year cuz
you're born on the 23rd yeah this is
2023 you're about to be very famous I
said shut up you're a [__] Jew then
[__] you yeah yeah yeah and I and then I
Skyrock it and he said to me don't worry
it's going to continue up until past
Christmas Even the craziest one bro is
he told me YouTube boxing is what's
coming up next and Zur I was never going
to box I said no to all of it and zurka
has a second Peak coming by the end of
the year one week later zura had 100
went from you know how you get a couple
thousand views 200 I did 200,000 views
my first boxing match yeah and it was
within hour's notice they told me you
have to fight for $50,000 crypto and so
I never planned it never got the train
just rolled out of bed but it peaked at
200,000 viewers so think about it a
professional boxer they don't even get
10,000 people watching I lapped every
one of them and now my next contract
with boxing was million dollar contract
so he predicted and told him and this is
when what did he say exactly I just told
well you kept [__] talking he said
boxing yes he said boxing specifically
coming up next I told him specifically
week before you did it has another Peak
coming by the end of the year that's
crazy I swear to God that's where I was
like told you that of my balcony and the
the the scariest thing he told me is he
does certain math to find out if you
have a peak in your future or if you
should just have kids and lay low if you
don't have a peak in your future it
means you're not going to pop off again
you're done all your success is over
might as well lay low you basically have
to look at um and guess what he told me
for my future guy it's the mega Peak is
cir that's why he that's why he moved in
with yeah I did not move with you he's
my neighbor yeah this guy so but do you
need more information from the person
your no I don't need I don't knows right
now about your future you have to
understand I can't put stuff out there
cuz people are going to reverse engineer
what I'm doing oh yeah no I get that
here's all you know if he starts being
extra nice to you he predicts your Peak
is insanely high if he's extra if he's
rude with you it means you fell off
that's that's how he treats people on
their peaks shut the Z you fell off then
what if he what if he's like at the end
he's like oh well bro good luck he does
you know he does death Cod too
stop teach you that but no I was just
interested in the process but you know
you know all of this stuff just from the
birth date so then you okay do not stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop stop the
way I got into this was 911 okay I woke
up in the morning and I think I'm
watching like Die Hard the movie Bruce
Wills then I figure out oh wow a second
plan hit the World Trade Center and then
I'm looking all this numbers I'm like
wait a second 911 the first plane to hit
the World Trade Center is flight 11 the
Twin Towers look like an 11 side by side
they both have 110 stories New York City
11 letters New York's the 11 standing
Union I'm like whoa what the [__] is
this even world one so the thing that
really got me into this was I remembered
World War I ended at 1111 at exactly 11
o'clock at that point someone's doing
something and then that's when I started
doing my investigating and it it took a
while I BAS basically secluded myself in
the room for years just looking this I
used to go to cemeteries look at
people's birthdays look when they died
and try to figure out why they died
based off that I got real real good at
this to the point where I'm the only
numerologist ever invited to the White
House and Golden State yeah well I hope
the Golden State Warriors went was it
Biden or Trump come on man come on Trump
come on man don't don't don't insult me
like that man [__] Biden [__] Biden do I
need to say that anymore [__] Biden I
really and let me tell you something I
have not Drank In Like A decade when Joe
Biden dies I'm drinking I'm putting the
[__] straight on
Twitter when Joe Biden dies we're doing
cocaine on the 11th when he dies we're
having a party you know what's funny um
I had a show yesterday and it was
basically like very like city girls I
guess like completely and I was curious
I didn't realize how conservative
Florida is cuz I just I was like Trump
2024 and everyone's like woo and I was
like I didn't expect that cuz they were
so like like City yeah yeah and I was
like Wow everyone's like a conservative
is there any Biden any Biden fans here
have you been have you been up north
like up north to Central Florida like
out like in the boonies when you go up
there there's like [__] Biden Flags
there's Trump there's Trump 20 2024
Flags yeah it's amazing even Miami they
they say it's more liberal I walk around
with the Trump hat and people like honk
honk and know that's why I was surprised
that I've just started like doing that
in rooms there are there are liberals
here before Dan santis this was a purple
State and it's gone more and more red
now but and so there's still here that's
because of Co because all the people
wanted to move down here and people like
me from California came here that's true
so the Liberals moved in yeah but the
Liberals moved in and it's still a red
state so like how you know well no I
came from a liberal state I'm from Los
Angeles California M I came here for
freedom I Boston there's people like us
that move here from Blue States and you
know the so you moved from Boston do
people tell you don't Massachusetts my
Florida um yeah absolutely I people me
don't California I I actually got dirty
looks until I finally changed my plates
to Florida plates it was funny not often
but I get a few you know like real
rednecky looking cars looking at me like
like like and I was like I'm on your
side believe me I'm not I'm not here I'm
here to double down in what you're doing
I come from a red State Ohio and I
helped Donald Trump wi in 216 at least
that state so Ohio's never going blue my
vote basically
doesn't my vote basically doesn't count
in
Chicago to many lials so what do you
guys think do you guys think that they
stole last election yes talk about this
yeah let's talk about it this on YouTube
it's not my channel [__] yeah they
did what are you doing bro oh can you
not talk about that on YouTube 100% the
election was stolen you don't I remember
at 3:00 in the morning I'm looking it
looks like a landslide for Trump all of
the sudden all these absentee ballots
come in y so so 100% Biden's a usurper
and Trump was the legitimate president
of the United States and that's why I
still call President Trump because
that's what the hell he is well then you
have the Dominion software as well which
was developed in the late 80s and early
90s through the International Business
Machines since my father was a software
engineer for IBM and helped did the
early development that what you might
get for Dominion we'll just cut back in
the 90s um like CNN
did excuse me you probably know more
about this but they did an expose on
those machines and saying how they could
be manipulated and it could it could all
be messed with and then all of that just
disappeared in Democrats that's why
right you know you have to understand in
our election system it's it's very
difficult to basically steal all the
state elections
because you have state representatives
and it's very difficult but when it
comes down to Democrat strongholds like
uh Pennsylvania especially Philadelphia
um Atlanta when it comes to Georgia they
can swing the vote there they can steal
no one's ever going to stop him there so
the only way Republicans can actually
win votes is by landslides they have to
win by a landslide if it's a close vote
Democrats are going to steal it every
single time and next term is going to be
Obama's fourth term but Trump would have
won if it was a landslide right yes if
it was a landslide Trump would win 100%
you cannot steal from Landslide I I
think because of how Trump handled Co
that's why it wasn't a landslide warp
speed yeah well it's not it's not that
he was also pressured by the House of
Representatives as well because it the
House of Representatives was mostly
Democrat as well as the the Senate of
the 2018 elections because when you when
you had the midterm elections that
totally got [__] because look what
happened the Democrats took over that
that happens every time a presidents in
power that when they hit the midterms of
year three they always lose power
happened to Barack Obama happened to
Bill Clinton happened to all them Fair
Point you know what's weird is you could
have been high level politician you're
an 11 you could have destroyed that game
I I would I would if she could have been
that Senator right I would I would want
how many El are I wouldn't want to be in
politics though because you sell your
soul you take bribes and all other well
you're a woman you shouldn't be
anyways it's it's not even that I just
wouldn't want want to do it because it's
soulless as [__] that's to be honest I
honestly think feminism died in 1994
with the domestic violence act you think
feminism died I think it should have
died then I mean like that's I mean
feminism wasn't needed after that
feminism stands for the trans community
so it's like you know I think women
should be in politics however I feel
like anybody that goes into politics
should actually take a [__] IQ test
man and women look at all the woke
people in the house I think I think
women can't be in politics because they
will never understand violence the way
that men do like that that's why
especially in in a president position
like I I just would never I will not
vote for a woman you know what I I think
women should vote I think women should
vote however I will never vote for a
female president because if that [__]
is going through menop oh my God
n okay okay but hear me out don't you
think that women that are not net
taxpayers should not vote like people
that are not like if you're in more debt
if you spend if you're if you're a net
tax taker like if you're on benefits why
are you going to say I don't think
people on benefits should vote yeah I
don't I don't think people that like um
I mean obviously felons can't vote what
I was about to say but it's it's like
living that's benefits you should vote
and that's more my point like if you
take out the women that are on benefits
if you take out the women that are
taking child support alimony like all of
this like free [__] from the government
that part I will agree with you not even
Mo but and if you take out women like if
we made it only military members could
vote if we made it only infrastructure
jobs like the amount of women that would
be voting is significantly less to the
point they're not going to be
influencing elections like they are now
I have a question how many people on
benefits are voting do we know I don't
know I don't know even their dead
relatives are voting yeah my grandma
apparently voted democat said thank you
okay you don't my grandma's a liberal I
can't believe I mean just by like
without even looking it's like think
about it you get a free Burger you go
why would you not vote if you're on
government
benefits you have everything to gain
they're brainwashed into thinking that
voting Democrats going to save them and
then they give them incentives to go and
vote like all the immigrants that are
coming here about let's go let's [__]
go the real problem is what the number
is the real problem is the Browning of
America cuz then they're voting blue
every time we keep pushing this hey
let's just bring all immigrants from
across the world sure but there even if
you brought only white people from
Europe white people from Europe are
socialist blue homosexuals the problem
is immigration it's not build the wall
it's put some more guards on top of
there look at Los Angeles look how many
homeless people went the the homeless
population imploded 100,000 from 10
years ago it was the 1962 Immigration
Act that basically uh changed everything
uh before we only took the brightest
immigrants we only took the people the
iq's the rich people after 62 the white
man's racist all that garbage can't
start coming now they take everybody I
would now this is coming from a
immigrant's son I'm telling people right
now I would shut down the border and I
would only let people with high IQs and
people who actually have money in the
country we have enough of our own poor
people I'm sorry we have enough of our
own poor people I want to take care of a
a wounded American Veteran before I give
my money to someone in gu
I'm I'm a refugee to this country and I
should have been left in my war zone cuz
I'm not a Christian it should be
Christians only here and Jesus is King
Jesus is King make it a Catholic
theocracy that's the only way you fix
the world cuz think about it you know
before Christ they were having sex with
children goats on Pagan Temple steps 10
people orgies and imagine some some dude
had psychic revelations and said man and
woman must be paired together they fixed
they fixed the pro every problem with
marriage and before Christianity there
was no marriage it was just rapist
pedophiles and Weirdos well the Bible
the Bible
was what about leontis leonitis Plato
Pythagoras what they all had in common
they had boy lovers they all were gay
with boy lovers they all had a little
boy that they touched and Christianity
said nope male and female L you can't be
gay it's Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
they say let's go let's go look at these
Els man [__] with these 11s marriage
existed debauchery existed but marriage
ex lat on them were having orgies in
Temple baths there everyone was just
having ories marriage is a Christian
thing 100% the Greeks and the Romans
were [__] degenerate but they were
but they were married Jews were married
thew were church and the state are
together and that's why marriage doesn't
benefit well and another problem with
marriage is is is is that we're not a
religious generally speaking we're not a
religious Society anymore so so well so
the contract of marriage is now not
worth anything and also the social
contract you know people don't give a
[__] if
people make divorce illegal do you know
what the biggest lie is that America is
this Christian Nation it's not it's not
she's going to talk about the Freemasons
no I'm not even no I'm not no I'm not
even talking about Wasington Freemason
secular homos no no no I'm not talking
about the free America America has been
leading the way in divorc since the
1600s since before America was America
they were not viewed as religious by the
world they were viewed as like
debauchery yeah but compared to us right
now compared to us Shar Christian law
but my point is then America led the
downfall of the West when it comes to
morals yes that's like so so
I wonder I wonder I wonder I didn't know
we're going to start talking about
Israel ruining America are we talking
about the Jews ruining America are we
going to bleep this part out but not
then that's 1962 what happened they took
over Zionist Lobby can I give a can I
give a concrete example to prove what
you're saying please bleep that out
Pearl I trust whatever I just said I I
okay yeah okay here's a concrete example
to prove what you just said here we have
somebody who has talked about
Catholicism all night long
but you know more you know far less
about the Bible than you do about the
devil's numbers oh cuz I met him this
month I just met
him you're playing in
idolatry and you're and you're talking
about Catholicism and and they don't
they don't coexist together I'm not
saying you have to have one or the other
be one or the other do whatever you want
where we have free will
but are you scared are you scared of 666
no no why not it says it's the devil's
number why you not scared you're a
Christian Superstition it's Superstition
just it has nothing to do with the devil
I want you guys to think about this 60
seconds in the minute 6 Plus 0 is 6 60
minutes an hour 6 Plus 0 6 24 hours in a
day 2 plus 4 is 6 there's your 666 it's
time itself so again the the the stuff
that's in the Bible you're not supposed
to take it literally you're not supposed
to take it
literally I say I say you say I trust
you take it literal I don't take it
literal man I trust the word of God over
the word the Bible has been Rewritten
like a thousands of times what are you
talking about which Bible are you
believing the King James one or the one
before which one actually there are if
you look at all of the differences in
all of the versions the basic Doctrine
is absolutely the same I have an I
actually have an answer for this why are
we pretending ltic has changed the law
has been the same don't listen to these
guys you you trust the institution of
the church because by that logic then
nobody was a Christian when they
couldn't print
it yeah I don't trust anyways I'm
Catholic so that's why we that's why
well I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about the institutions because
there is corruption in in loads of the
in institutions that's not and that's
not disputed and I I would never defend
the Catholic church for what they did
and how they [__] hid do you know why
Jesus is do you know why Jesus is the
most uh famous dead man in the world 33
there you go he died exactly when he was
33 years old old 33 is the number of
influence that's why that's why the
Masonic order goes up to 33° because
they know certain things yes that is no
it's because he rose from the dead so Z
you know what's funny is you believe in
Carl Young talking about synchronicity
but three was it 8 billion people on
Earth share the mental plane that Jesus
existed at least you're telling they're
you're saying they're all wrong there
the synchronicity is 8 billion people
are not wrong it's not 8 billion because
they don't have to be they know he's
real who knows he's real the Buddhist
say Buddhist say he's real Jews say he's
real Muslims say he's real seen have you
seen them everyone say seen are you you
believe something what something you
haven't seen it's called Faith okay so
this is why I believe in faith the hell
with that I need facts so here's what
I'm going to tell you people okay you
can feel things without seeing them I
can't see the wind I can put my hand
outside the window and feel it there's a
difference there's archaeological and
historical evidence dinosaurs now there
500 Witnesses in Rome 500 witnesses
witnesses Jes this is what I know I know
there's Jesus and 12 disciples just like
there's one judge and 12 jurors just
like there's one son and 12 astrology
signs it's all a system it's all a
system you guys need to stop doing this
stuff actually zura so how do you how do
you balance that because you believe in
the numerology stuff but you're also a
Catholic do you believe they can like
coexist I think a lot of the Bible's
been Chang but the truth remains marry a
woman that's [__] evidence but I
don't believe I don't believe uh there's
parts to talk about don't eats shellfish
I don't think that's God's word I think
they put that in there because it was at
that time they didn't want to eat the
[__] shellfish there's parts that say
give the evangelicals they believe give
money to the Jews God never said give
money to the Jews what the [__] no but
but I'm I'm asking like do you like cuz
her point is that like what he's saying
is like demonic almost well it's
divination so any predicting the
predicting the future is against it's
against the I joke about the devil's
numbers mostly but it is idolatry and we
are forbidden from you believe in a
system that's outside of the word of God
believing in any yes in any God or power
that's not what would get me in trouble
it's divination it's predicting future
which is against the bible let me tell
you guys something in about 50 maybe
even 40 years it's not going to be
Christianity it's not going to be Islam
it's not going to be Judaism it's not
going to be U Buddhism it's going to be
numerology and astrology people no I
don't give a damn what people say that's
going to be the evolution because
there's only one universal language and
that's mathematics and honestly God gave
us those God gave us those numbers and
if you go against the if you believe my
numbers are up to 33 if you believe my
numbers are evil then so is your Quran
so is your Bible so's your Torah cuz my
numbers are all over them yeah there's
like the seven Trumpets the numbers are
all over the Bible so I'm not going to
ignore that right but if I chose my wife
based on her numerological sign that is
as successful as his marriage is with
his kid I think that's pretty crazy that
you're choosing a number and not who
you're 20 years brother but now check it
out check it out funny I didn't deny I
didn't deny that that that he's you SED
you're right it is kind of bad it is
kind of bad to learn this stuff but so
tired of being screwed like I really
when when I met that girl May
25th and she came with and my first
allegation ever he said avoid her and I
said [__] no one day out of the year you
must be crazy he said that's the only
girl banished from your content house
and he was right within 24 hours so
you're worried about getting screwed in
this life but what about this life short
what about all the Everlasting eternity
like are you more are you
here's I'll be honest Gary is a better
person than everone at this table cuz I
was when I brought him to this party and
some super model tried to found out he's
Rich try to kiss him on the cheek I've
never seen a man get away from me I'm
married I've never seen say's the devil
just for the record and I don't think
that a lot of people your
and and yeah I think if you use if you
use that I'm enjoying your company the
way I see numerology is you're it's like
these guys watching porn or it's
sinning that's see it numerology you see
you see numerology sin but Jesus died
for your sin so if you're not sinning
then Jesus died for nothing but you but
you by instant yeah I can't stop doing
the ma when I meet people I can't stop
sinning I shake someone's hand and he's
going to work with me I can't stop doing
the math in my head because of how
accurate it's been for
me but uh it it feels like I'm it feels
like I'm born when I do anyone who's
going to be around me for a while is
going to start thinking like him even
Sunny to a points already there to a
little bit but I'll never go to
reincarnation and all that I'll always
be reincarnation part of numerology
though or separate that's a separate
because I believe there's old souls and
there are young souls okay and what I've
seen is reincarnation has to be real
because how do we have older Souls
that's actually an interesting point cuz
you've always said that's why I don't
agree with Islam but you've always said
that I was an old soul from when I was
young I us to believe that I used to
believe that you don't believe anymore
anymore I don't tell you right now he's
older Soul than you wait so I have a I I
have a question how do you know how how
can you say that look at his birthday
tell wait so I have a I have a question
do you think that like once you do life
right then you stop or you always are
reincarnating no no I believe that um
you said I I believe you go through the
1- n system then it's 1122 33 and if you
pass the hardest reincarnation 33 then
you might go to the fourth dimension you
you you pass through this
threedimensional realm which we're in
right now because right now we're in a
third density realm after we actually
reincarnate to the point where we get
Consciousness to the point where we
understand what we don't understand now
then we go to a higher realm but you're
talking about like maybe one out of very
10 okay so you believe that but you
don't believe that Jesus could have
risen from the dead like you believe in
the Supernatural no I believe he could
have been reincarnated is that what
you're telling me he was reincarnated I
don't believe what evidence do you have
for reincarnation I hardly believe
something that bleeds and doesn't die
what come on oh great great that's great
high level sexist but the interesting
thing is he believes in numers so much
that in the three threedimensional World
we're in is the creative world four is
Law and Order so he believes the next
Dimension will be more lawful that
that's why we have the four horsemen
fourth dimension but will the whole
eventually would the whole planet go
through some
four
very few people very few most people
fail their
reincarnation honestly many I'll Flow To
Heaven you know see all my dead
relatives and they're like waving at me
like like I'm at an airport and I'm like
guess who's dead [__] here's why here
here's why the Bible is against the
stuff is it you deal with greed one of
the seven deadly sins so if you know
certain numbers make you more money are
you going to just do the math you're
head or you going to abuse it if you
know certain girls bring you more wealth
are why are they falling in love with
you so you can take money out that the
greed aspect is what makes knowing this
stuff horrible now manipulation aspect
yeah yeah manipulation so you so it
works then you agree if it works if you
saying you can manipulate people with
this stuff then you agree it works I
didn't agree it works but I'm I'm just
I'm can you can you use it for you're
saying it's manipulated you can
manipulate the future you're saying it's
kind can drive a car canri for a peri
time get addicted I can drive a car and
kill someone that doesn't make the car
bad it's how you use the
knowledge I was going to say he believes
in Karma so he clearly is not
manipulating because that's just going
to add Bad Karma to him and since he's
the 33rd he's on his last reincarnation
he believes so he has to convert as many
you have to save as many he has to save
he has to save as many Souls as possible
or else he [__] up he has to be a good
guy this time I still haven't heard a
really good explanation for this
reincarnation thing because where energy
and energy cannot be distorted it can
only transferred so that you just means
we're connected to One Source that does
yeah we're connected to God and you have
one life on this planet if you read the
Bible that's what it says yeah it says
you have yes we are energy which was
created by God but religion and physics
are not the same yeah it's not religion
it's intertwined religion and look just
look at it this way Carl Young the
greatest you still haven't
answered let me just say this let me
just say this um it
the scientists in the past 60 50 years
have discovered that when it's a full
moon people act a little bit crazy
because you know the moon pulls on the
ties 70% of the human body is water so
it affects us too the astrologers knew
that a thousand years ago huh that's
what I'm trying to tell you the
astrologers in some ways are way ahead
of the scientist today
I I saw that doesn't negate God not even
a little bit God made the St prove God
is real I'm not I can't prove God is
isn't real way I'm not an atheist I do
believe I do believe but I can't prove
it neither can you neither can anyone at
this table that's the that's the no you
can't you can't how can you prove God is
real Carl Young proves Sy synchronicity
is real if 8 billion humans share the
Jesus idea in their head then the Matrix
will manifest Jesus doesn't mean it's
real mean that means it's literal truth
no it why would it be shared in 8
billion people's brains is it a
coincidence that's [__] most people
believe that there's no there are no
coincidences according to car most
people believe that there is no rough
TRS running the world so just because
people believe it doesn't mean it's real
I will say I will say this I will say
this when a lot of people believe in
something it does help manifest
something but that doesn't mean the
manifestation is real that's because the
Matrix just provides what people want to
see yeah so that same could be true for
numerology yes like manifestation our
Tempo hats on right now manifest I'm not
disagreeing with you no no here's what
he's saying all the billions zillions
trillions of Dollars around the Vatican
circulates one book but it's a fairy
tale to him what a [__] horeshit bro
all the money thousands been re it
doesn't matter that's it doesn't matter
now okay for thousands years everyone's
kill each other that book but the book
is just Peter Pan get the [__] out of
here 100% brother 100% all of the if you
add up every single difference in every
version of the Bible some of them are
simple like site errors writing errors
um different um some of them so they'll
say you know there are thousands uh uh
the Jews are God's chosen people yes or
no the real Jews yeah I actually am not
really um so you don't in the Bible it
says that in the Bible don't put words
in my [__] mouth what I said what I
was about to say was I haven't I haven't
mastered that part of the Bible so I'm
not really sure why talking about stuff
you don't know but that's one I'm
sayange I know I know enough to have a
conversation should I just I have to be
an expert on every
in the Bible a lot of people talk about
it everyone thinks they're they're
Specialists because we have the internet
so like now like with the Gaza and the
the Israel thing going on we all have
these political experts now yeah true
but I I feel like you're being factious
with me because I am studying the Bible
and I'm learning you know and this is
where this okay what version of the
Bible I'm just being honest King James
version or what what version of the
Bible um I read the NIV and the ES King
James that's like that's like you
remember the G telephone and then by the
time it gets around the table it's like
totally different from the original but
what but what you won't let me finish so
it's it's some a lot of the errors are
site errors so it's somebody it with a
[__] candle and some sheep skin and a
little pen copying and so they'll write
the same word twice or they'll skip a
word a lot of them if you add a if you
add them up are you know like I said
misn numbering a verse because somebody
is tired and they they're translating or
it's a word that's lost in a language
translation that is about 95% and of the
other 5% none of them are material and
affect the doctrine none never never it
never said go it never said go the Jews
were God's chosen people in the Bible
until the 1900s it did not say that in
1800s it said that in 1900 because they
needed the Christians in this country to
have public opinion so to go for the
Jews so they could go and build a Jewish
homeland in Israel that is why the Bible
was Rewritten fact yeah but the point is
you accept Jesus you get saved that
part's never
Rewritten so you're saying there are
hundreds of versions and all over the
world in all these versions all these
people colluded and conspired to do this
telephone for a for a conspiracy theory
you have to to to be effective you have
to have a minimal number of people
involved have money you have to have no
there's just no way I I have a I have
money I open a publishing company I
rewrite the Bible start giving out to
churches it's very simple that's exactly
what they did like
telephone and by the way by the way the
Quran was never Rewritten that's why
people have more faith in that than the
Bible oh really cuz it came hundreds of
years after still still was never
Rewritten though the point is the point
is if it comes if if it comes hundred
years hundreds of years after 600 years
after clearly then it's not real I got
you no the yeah so so you're telling and
you're telling the Torah wasn't
Rewritten these aren't even the same
Jewish people they go by Oral talmudic
Babylonian law they're going by Oral law
you're you're talking Zionism talking
Zionism sure sure the Torah says Jews
are not allowed a Homeland because
they're under God's law not state law
they're not allowed Israel that's true
so how are you saying it's the same
Jewish people what do you mean it's
clearly different no no no no I said
there's Zionist there's zionists and
there's Jews there's a big difference
what is the difference Zion believe Jews
should have a Homeland uh Jews do not
yeah cuz God does God says they should
spread around Earth which stop spreading
get
away okay well it's getting late so
let's let's close out the show Christ is
King let's go let's go
man um and if you've ever hit a woman
God loves you and you can repent okay
come to my website theer official.com
where I teach you to not abuse women oh
my God okay why don't we do final
thoughts I'm starting here and then go
oh my God I'm always first with this
[__] I don't know I feel like pretty
like uneducated on a lot of this stuff
like talking about religion and whatnot
so it's kind of he's just here to plug
his socials just go ahead Sunny
Faz I I know him too well bro I know him
too well this is the businessman I'm the
best short form marketer in the world if
you need any short form work done I'm
the guy all right on thank you for
contributing that was amazing that was
electric when you almost spoke it was
crazy but uh I am obviously here to say
Jesus is God I've been a Christian for
what seven months and I skyrocketed in
Fame but without the death nothing to do
with this being 2003 and you being born
on 223 nothing to do with that no of
course not and that's Gary okay so but
guys remember remember Gary's had
thousands of students but he only
invested million dollars on the [__]
Christian I wonder why where your
Buddhist where your where the other he
only invested in the guy who's who's
having theological debates for Christ
this year imagine for 20 years 20 years
he got none of them a house none of them
nothing he invests in the Christian but
he says Christianity's [__] he just
got super lucky around me somehow let me
tell you something Gary will be a
Christian before
I'm look at that that's the devil's
laugh I will be listen I'm a Jew by name
I don't believe in any of that stuff
either okay
twitter.com cir official join my cocaine
Crusader Crusade join me in taking
women's rights away but doing but doing
it in a cool way where they're like
laughing and they we get their phone
numbers and [__] yes let go listen
there's a way there's a way to take
women's rights away and for have them
agree to it it's very simple women have
80% of the debt in this country we
cancel your debt we take away your vote
most women women in this country will go
for that I promise you okay that's most
women in this country will go for that
number two numerology and astrology are
the only Universal languages in the
world Numbers Never Lie men lie women
lie Numbers Never Lie gg33 anywhere and
you'll see billions of views you can
tell a woman is lying cuz her mouth is
moving twitter.com/zeromd
uh this has been fascinating and the
relationship between you two guys is
really fascinating because it seems like
there's some like ideological
differences here but you guys are
obviously very tight and it
seems my friend my friend in London said
to me you need a Jewish right hand man
so I don't know man but it seems like it
makes me look like I don't hate the Jews
hanging around me yeah it's a good cover
so antism yeah so it's interesting to
see how that develops but listen uh
thanks for having me on P it's been
great as always myself and Tiffany are
currently working on a course all about
sex and how to do sex better so yeah
yeah because she's a professional so she
knows what so uh sorry a veteran indeed
I'm using my my my my past life to help
other people so that's going to be
coming up very soon but you can follow
me on YouTube Twitter and Instagram real
Troy Francis
thanks you know where your energy comes
from her voice is that 11 yeah that's
best when you speak the room vibrates
not an no you know what it is it's Mara
Reds is it from people pissing me off
she puts energy when she speaks do 11
speak like this if I don't quit smoking
now if I quit
smoking with that [__] voice yeah
she's a corner McGregor energy he's 11
she's small just like Obama but that big
ass voice comes out I like dick just
like Obama
too let's go you know Obama's brother
was there yesterday he was sitting the
right there yesterday yeah I feel bad um
poor guy know I feel bad that he's
related to Barack Obama say poor guy um
yeah no um this has been fine um doing
the course of Troy you guys should check
it out um you can find me at one bad Fox
on all social media with an underscore
no ghetto spelling I spell everything
out and you can also I have a Channel
all in with tip I'm starting a podcast
try to help women get out of corn
and you know it helped me out take
account accountability I'm not really
proud of it but it got me where I wanted
to be wait what's wrong with farming huh
corn corn I got to add my dad jokes to
look yeah I look more Rel now right
right I'm trying to be respectful not
you you know you can't just say you you
shouldn't say hey girls get out of corn
cuz that's boring and nobody clicks on
that you should literally say corn is of
the devil and you'll have a billion
followers you should go to war with that
[__] go to war with your past I went to
war with my drug dealing past now I'm
talking about Jesus I don't even drug
deal anymore I just take it up the nose
I used to grow pot in California so I
feel it but I'm saying you should be you
should be calling out corn stars and
saying they're demons you'll go viral
you'll be cancelled and your business
will grow there's great they're not
demons they're they may be taken by you
know bad influence of what they're under
the let me tell you about the women okay
there's a small percentage and anomaly
of them that are really good people like
myself but I don't like most of the
people in my industry CU they're batshit
crazy and they drug addicts I will say
that that's why I only hook up with only
fans girls no porn stars yeah but they
don't get tested so you you probably got
to get tested the hard way yeah someone
got the clap someone got someone got the
clap um Pearl thanks for having me on it
was honestly a pleasure listening to
everyone talk and meeting everyone
you're the most liberal here we hate you
if this was caveman times we'd be
cooking you and eating you we'd be all
killing you you're the most soft liberal
you need to change your CNN your fake
news you got to be like us you got to be
like Pearl that's what you got to do
anyways um you know I want to say she's
so sweet when I was like dislocated
shoulder and I was all perked out on
perco set she helped me in the hotel and
I was saying all crazy [__] and he
ghosted me you ghosted me twice now bro
he doesn't respond to
anyone
we're why are you doing this here don't
take it personal it's like everybody
yeah
okay my bad um but yeah I I believe in
CU you're a nine yeah I'm kidding you
adaptive nine I Believe In The Theory of
Everything I believe that we're all
connected in some way and I um think
we're all separated distracted and
focusing too much on the physical so
catch me talking about that on my
podcast Free Will and you can follow I'm
going to be on that podcast yeah we'll
see this time I'm not doing this a third
time yeah you should come on rockar I
told everyone you're going to be my
guest I'm coming for sure